Holy cow are recording.
Here we go.
The Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you.
What's going on with
this fucking that's cool.
You're both doing it.
No, I was silent. No,
we were by you or I'm going to
turn myself on. Where was I?
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name Rogan,
you will save 15% off a
slimy pink jerk off device.
And it's a good one. It's a
fabulous product. I've, okay.
Haven't used my yet. Use it. You
haven't used yet. That's ridiculous.
Let's make the music so it's official hit.
It doesn't feel like your podcast.
The blackout
[inaudible] Horace.
When I hear that music, I don't
win. That's how it starts.
But smile on my face. Wild Times.
I could live in a wild times.
Let's get on our horses and just ride.
I guess what I want to say once Dan a
pro and I could survive not talking to
anybody. Damn right. All I need is
a match, a Bowie knife. And my Dick.
So he's that character that
Charles Bronson dude who
wants to live in the woods
by himself and doesn't bother
anybody with the government,
has to go out there and fuck with them
and he winds up killing everybody.
What is it that we might admire about that
guy who doesn't need the American way?
Self sufficiency? Man, I
don't need anybody but myself.
I'm self-reliant. Yeah,
but you know with a lot of
guys like the, the, the,
the loner would be kind of creepy,
but Charles Bronson had a way of
pulling it off that was admirable.
Sure will do is nothing
Ted Kaczynski about him.
Charles Bronson was a bad ass and God
help you if you were a fan and tried to
come out to him.
I Ms. Guy.
I Know Adam West Batman told me a story
16 years ago about how Charles Bronson
was reading a book in a bookstore and
this guy comes in and goes, excuse me,
Mr Bryson, I'm a huge fan and
Charles Monster goes fuck off.
And it goes right back to his place.
Just like that guy was like, oh, okay.
It's hard to know how
much of that is the truth.
He was notorious full of shit.
He was notorious for being, uh,
just not the friend that he was a tough,
he was a real tough guy actually.
You know, when he did hard times, if
you'd never seen hard times. Youngsters,
youngsters, please. It's one of
the Goddamn all time classics.
It's a beautiful movie and
it's a, it's really like, uh,
the first like underground cage fighting
movie. They actually fun in a cage. Yup.
Bronson was in his fifties when he shot.
Was He in his 50s?
Because you see his body,
it's ridiculous.
You get a lot of native American in
him and I think he used to be like an
acrobat or something, something
along those lines. A circus I think.
Hey, we would with with Wikipedia
were just bullshit through this.
He was in the circus. Yeah. Yes. In
the circus. He did couple in Brazil.
In Brazil. He did couple. It's always
my favorite stuff when people go, no,
this guy, I know this guy. He
wasn't, it wasn't UFC dude.
He fought in the underground in Burma.
He has a confirmed
kills belt.
There was a lot of guys who just made
up a bunch of shit like that in the 70s
and the,
remember the the guy who they did the
movie kickbox well not kickboxing bloods
bloodsport yeah, frank ducks. Yeah. Yeah.
He's a Ninjitsu guy. Went out there,
there's a coma tain just
fucked everybody up.
Supposedly he had a story number
Dimock which was death touch.
There was a guy named Raphael Toria
and I've talked about this guy before
because this guy snuck through my
crazy radar and I realized that he was,
there was something wrong and then
it turned out he was a killer.
Like I didn't know I was around this guy.
He was a friend of a friend who was a
friend of Eddie's and I was around this
guy a couple of times and normally
my crazy radars are really good,
but this guy snuck right through it
and he was such a pathological liar.
This is one of the things that he did.
He was a fake black belt who,
one of the things he did was he had a
friend drive him to this spot and he said,
I'm going into the woods.
You can't come any further.
I'm going to go to this [inaudible]
and I'll be back in two days.
So his friends drives them into the woods
and then he sees him like walk around
and like hide behind a tree and he
flipped the fuck is he doing right?
So he kind of hangs back to watch and the
dude starts walking back down the road
where he came from like, so the guy
drives off, right? Because like,
I dunno what the fuck is.
His deal was,
but he wanted to be dropped
off in the woods. He,
the guy comes back two days later
with a trophy. I kind of like,
he comes out of the woods. Well, he
has a story about, well, I had a fight,
50 men all bare knuckle. Some guys
chose to have glass on their hand.
Some guys not just had just crazy nutty.
Meanwhile,
feigning while his prompts
finding stories. Guy Fuck fest,
I got to put this handkerchief in
my pants. Don't worry about it.
It's just a signal. It was nothing.
There was no, nothing happened.
He made up the whole thing. There was no
Kuma Tej out there and he just came off.
He just went, yeah, it's same thing.
I had the guy in a headlock that I fucked
him while he wound up killing a guy by
choking him to death. Oh really? Yeah.
That's the stories that this guy,
he was just as crazy pathological liar
and he wound up hooking up with this girl
and the girl was married and he choked
her husband to death. Oh Nice guy.
In real life when you choke
somebody to death and stiff,
like just choking him like Jujitsu style,
you have to like continue the choke
on when they're already passed out.
Just hold it.
Cause like in the movies it's like Ah.
And then they pass out and they're like,
ah, he's dead. You know. But in real life,
some people would die from
it and glorious bastards.
When he choked her with his hands. That's
really hard to do. Really hard to do.
Even put a guy out by choking
him was, you know, it hurts,
but it's all a matter of how much
you can tolerate. You know, it's the,
it's cuts your breathing off
cause it's crushes your windpipe.
If the guy's got good thumbs,
but it probably won't put you
unconscious tars tars so you can do it.
It's not something I practice,
but some guys will tap to that like,
like it kickboxers when we
first started fighting and MMA,
they tapped to like forearms across
the neck. Like a guy will just stack,
I'm going to get a form on their neck
and they just can't deal with it.
I don't know how to react to it.
Yeah, I've seen it a few times.
Like high level kickbox
just like Tom Erickson,
I think Tom Erickson did actually
tap a guy with a rape joke.
He actually grabbed his neck like this.
Wow. What we would call the rape choke.
Wow. Yeah. And he tapped the
guy in humanly strong hands.
So Tom Erickson was 300 pounds.
That American wrestler gorilla,
you're going to tap.
There's one point in time
when Tom Erickson was the
scariest guy in the planet
and he kind of missed both boats as far
as like fame and a lot of people don't
know about Erickson because of that.
But if you go back to
like when Erickson fought,
fought Kevin random and it smashed
him and knocked him unconscious,
he was fucking like really close to 300
pounds corn fed because one of those big
crazy white boys just in a powerful
wrestler. Just a real good rest.
I'd love to have a rape joke strength
with other guys. Just grab a guy, go,
you're going out with Ericsson.
We got,
he was getting famous right at the time
where the UFC was falling apart and so
he went to fight over in Japan
and he just never really,
it just his, the peak of his
athletic talent and the peak of his,
his uh, possibilities. They
didn't collide together correctly.
Thanks. I was thinking about
it, it's like just for MMA,
like if you're a tennis players,
have MMA seems to be to stay on top,
but what the way say Anderson Silva or
GSP has is so extraordinarily difficult
because there are so many good guys now
coming up and more importantly it looks
to me like a lot of these guys are
really learning how to box cause they're
coming out of boxing gyms.
When you learn how to box and you can
punch now instead of like punching like a
wrestler, they're punching like
boxers. When you don't have gloves,
you make one mistake.
You're going to sleep
guy Fabio Maldonado that's been fighting
out of Brazil and he just fought
recently and this fucking kid is,
he's got nasty hands dude and eat for
Kyle Kingsbury who's like a serious
athlete,
two Oh five and Kyle Kingsborough was
grabbing in the Meu Thai clinch and he was
just ripping hooks to his body and
Kingsbury had to let it go, which is rare.
Most of the times when a guy gets you
into noise and I clench and he punches
body,
that guys can take it.
But he turns his punches over so
good and he's so loose with them.
They just buy it by him. Like there,
there were just vicious body punches.
You see the difference between
a guy who could really punch.
Like if you got a guy like Manny Pacquiao
and you gave him those little gloves
getting, let me tell you something, man.
If you don't take Manny Pacquiao down
the first five 10 seconds, that fight
back of Ricky Hatton headwind and what
that Hook, oh, I thought he was dead too.
I've never been like, oh
my God, he got shut off.
The thing about Pacbio is he's a
little guy. He's only 140 750 pounds,
but he hits fucking hard for
a little guy. Dude, I've,
I've watched him physically hit the pants.
Freddie Roach was holding pads for him.
I watched it and dude, first of all,
the punches come so fast
and all of them are hard.
It's not so like maybe like there's a
guy who could punch 40% harder than,
but he might only hit you once. Pat Cow's
going to hit you 18 fucking that time.
I think a lot of guys can't
train for that kind of speed.
You can get your sparring partners,
you can't like when I watched
what he did to Margarito who
is a bigger guy and has been towards
and has actually never been hurt.
Margarita is a rough,
when he got hurt by Mosley before that,
but he still psychologically fuck cause
they caught him with a plaster and his
gloves and we made them fight anyway.
That's crazy shit.
He knew he was going to be
suspended and he's going to be
such an assassin and to see Manny pat
can take a bigger man like that and do
whatever. He was a monster.
Packy I was one of the,
if not the greatest of all
time, top two. I mean I think,
I think I would think he's number one
just to, and people will argue with it,
but God dammit, he's won world titles
in eight different weight classes.
Who the fuck has every done that? I would
love to have seen him fight. Um, Duran.
Yeah. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Duran at one 47 the Duran,
that beach sugar ray.
And the first fine crazy and that
really wasn't as best weight class.
Darren's best way class.
It was one 35 one 35 was one of the
greatest lightweight of all time.
If you watch like it's fight with
Ken Buchanan when he won the title,
he was fucking vicious. Panama's
street kid. Unbelievable.
Just the animal man was a born fighter.
You see what these documentaries on
that guy and it's like a pit bull.
It's like a gain bred dog,
like a guy to interview him space.
Then when to interview him in Panama when
he was a kid, when he was a contender,
when he was coming up and they're
following them in the streets,
asking them about boxing.
Where'd you learn at a box and
in front of these reporters,
he grabs a cat by the tail and throws
it into a brick wall. Oh my God. Yeah,
in front of them. You know,
he, I remember when they,
there was an old interview and you could
probably youtube it where he's being
asked by like Brent Musburger,
someone about his fight with Macho Hector
Macho Comacho he hits some fight with
you. No, it was later
on in his career. And,
and you'd hear him say some
stuff and like Spanish,
but I didn't know that was one of
them might have corn and, and uh,
well I uh, then there's the interpreter
say, um, cause it, cause Brenmar hospital.
What do you feel that you're, you're
fighting an outside, it's going to be hot.
Is the heat going to affect you or do you
think you're used to that? You know, uh,
against someone like macho
who moves around so much in
a ring light, he goes, hey,
just go ahead and just put it on. And
medical. Then, uh, he's referring to, uh,
Mr. Camacho is a homosexual
and so, so much. Yeah.
So Martin [inaudible],
I'd be like, well yeah,
but don't you think that you're fighting
now with 10 ounce glass wasn't 12 ounce
gloves now and you, you are a harder
hit her. I'm a lot of people saying,
do you think that's going to favor
unified? You going to go to the body,
you think more than the
chin, Mitochondria, tenor.
And he's still a referring to Mr. Watson.
I'm a sexual and, and if I think it
the third time I'm, or whoever it was,
Ms. Berger and he's like, uh, he's,
he's still calling him a homosexual man.
That's a Roberto Duran. I guess we're
not going to get anything out of him.
You know, he was impossible man. He
was just like, dude, I think fighter.
Well it also, you mean he
grew up in Panama? Man,
I think if you grow up in a tough country,
you know,
you grow up in a spotlight that you grew
up poor Noriega and they say Noriega
and he were friends.
Like Noriega liked him a lot.
Like when they have more on everybody,
Roberto Duran,
you can't not love a true fighter. He's
a true fighter representing your country.
They had other guys you say be a
Pedroza wasn't here from Panama as well.
I think he was
Cuba. I don't really know.
I don't remember. I thought
he was from Panama but,
but Duran was one of my favorite fighters
of all time and the guy couldn't even
speak English. It didn't matter.
He just was such a savage.
She's going to be interesting to see like
guys like Nick Diaz are coming out of
Andre Ward's camp and stuff and these
guys who are really studying boxing and
even though it it, you have to know
everything and they may wish to.
What I love about it [inaudible] you are
going to get some guys who are going to
become, you know,
incredible boxers and the,
I think that the,
it's going to be an issue about you're
going to have fights that last that,
that are not,
you can't have very good punchers you
can't slip when you don't have gloves.
When guys can punch that hard.
I think it's going to,
something's going to
have to give them that.
You guys are going to get
mine as many mistakes. Yeah.
I mean Cain Valasquez is great,
right? We know how great he is now.
He has to fight jr Santos
and Santos can hit.
So somebody's going to catch somebody
in that fight and it doesn't necessarily
mean it's the better fighter.
It might mean that you just got caught
or your game plan was a little too hasty.
You gotta be very careful. You saw the
check Congo Pat Barry fight. Yes I did.
Which is the craziest NZ
in any fight ever. I mean,
that's a perfect example of why you have
to be so careful in MMA. It's unbelief.
And Pat Barry is explosive. Oh
my God. And he went after a man,
he decided that he was getting criticized
for his fights and he was kind of
boring. And people were
saying, he doesn't, you know,
take enough chances. Well,
he showed why he doesn't
take enough chances because
look, when you take chances,
you can get knocked the fuck out.
And he was a fun, it was a fight.
He was winning easily.
If he just fought at a discipline pace,
that probably would have never happened.
And that's experience. Yes. Experience.
But it's also, he chose to fight
in an exciting style on purpose.
He wanted to throw caution to the wind
and just go, you know, kill or die,
kill or be killed. And I
think he, uh, he did that.
He did exactly what he wanted to do, but
some guys never do that. And by the way,
Shit, Congo, taking those shots. God
Damn. I've never seen a body like that.
It's the most ridiculous
thing. So Superhero former
here. Yeah, he's a superhero.
He's a, he's a extreme mesomorph
that's what that guy is. He's good.
He's just super muscular, like
perfect athletic frame. You know,
he's not the best heavyweight athlete
though, which is weird. I mean it,
Cain Velasquez is a way
better heavyweight athlete,
which is weird cause if you
saw the two of them together,
I mean the average person looks at check
Congo and Cain Velasquez and you'll get
the fuck out of here. That black guy's
going to kill him. That's isn't that,
that's like wrestling.
Like you know,
you gotta you gotta like you roll in
Jujitsu and some guy comes in and he's got
this beautiful body and somebody he can,
you can move and manipulate and then a
guy shows up and he looks like a plumber
with a bit of a belly and he's
just like immovable. He's, yeah,
I think it's how your body is balanced.
That Congo is always dangerous to anybody
because he's got some pop in those
hands. Dude, he was the only guy to
really saw hurt her. ASCA is too,
he's tough as shit.
He went three full rounds with Cain and
Cain beat the fuck out of him in that
fight.
You know he's,
he's obviously durable cause Congo
caught him with some big punches.
Mere put them to sleep, but mere
got him in a guillotine. Mirrors.
Ganti it's nasty.
He and he did it so perfect.
If you watched the way he locked it up,
he's cinches it up.
He blocks off the neck with his arm
and squeeze squeezing with his right.
It's like it was, yeah. Mirror is one
of those guys, man, if he catches you,
especially in the early part of the fight
where he's not even a little bit tired
and you give up an arm or or,
or a choke or something like that and
he's going to break your neck, man,
you're off. I can't wait to
see my boy, man Miller, who
is my become a good friend.
I just love that guy.
I want to see him fight Michael Bisping.
It's going to be great, man. I just love
watching him. I love his whole attitude.
I love it. He never stops
moving. I will never stop moving.
I wish that people could
see what what he did.
But I was in Vegas and we were laughing
and talking and he kept moving around
and we're joking around.
And then finally he got so excited,
he w he walked out in the hallway anyway,
nobody was watching.
He'd just kind of punched the air and
ran down the hallway for no reason.
I was like,
he just spazzed out in the hallway and
got so excited and he came back in there.
Well, he knows he's got some extra energy.
He's got to get rid of it. Smart Guy,
by the way.
He's supposed to be doing what he's doing.
You know what's crazy is you can look
at him and see like that guy. Like,
I'm not going to fight that guy. That
guy's scary. But like last night, uh,
Jake was in the audience at one of your
shows. Oh, what's his name? Jake, right.
Jake Ellenberger. Yeah. Yeah. And
he sat in my seat and I'm like,
who's this guy sitting in my seat?
And I'm walking up and I like look at
his ears. I'm like, I'm Outta here.
Jake. Jake was there when
I was, Jake was there with,
he came to my show in Vegas with a,
with mayhem and yeah,
he's just got a fire
hydrant on his shoulders.
He took like clay and they chip.
They were a bad scope or they chipped
out like you know his head. Nah,
this is good enough. That dude's
a tank and he's a scary as fuck.
He's going to fight Jake shields.
That's going to be a very interesting,
he's very good. He's a very good
striker and she is prescribed, oh,
he's a lot better stroke then shields.
But shields has got some wicked
takedowns and some of his top Jujitsu.
Lucky if he gets on top of
you. Ooh, you're fucked.
Jake shields is one of
the best in the world at,
at finishing guys in MMA and Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is like real simple.
Like he's always used Nogi.
He's not not a gay guy.
So he doesn't have any key habits at all.
And he like, if he gets on top of you,
he's a wrestler.
So he's got awesome positioning control
and he's strong as fuck and he'll
squeeze off arm triangles on
you all day if he catches you.
If Jake shields gets on top of you
and he gets you in a bad position,
you're fucked man. Cause it's
like a level, it's a really high,
high level of Jujitsu
that that guy breaks.
If he gets you in a checkmate position,
the odds are that you're going
to squirm out of it. Like look,
he got Paul Daley and
elite Xc and elite XC.
They were fucking him by the fight goes
to the ground for more than 15 seconds.
They stand you up, like literally
told the referee. So stand fights up.
Even if they're active.
Like Roy Nelson got stood up when he
was in fucking side control working on a
Kamora and Andre Arlovski and they stood
him up. It was completely ridiculous.
Well Jake Shields Jujitsu was so tight.
He caught Paul daily with an arm bar.
Even under those rules, he
doesn't need much time. Dude.
He gets a guy like daily on the ground.
It's like, give me that pitch crazy.
He's just, it's just that
high level stuff, but he's
got to get it to the ground.
That's where Ellenberger
you can, if you can defend a take
down, that's a huge part of it.
Ellenberger moves good on his feet too.
That's the other thing. He's not a duty.
Just stands there like a robot.
Like there's some guys who just kind
of weighed in. He moves, he moves on.
It's feet and lose on is tough. That's a
tough fight. That's an excellent fight.
What's your calling the Biz Bang
Miller fight. Fucking I want,
can't wait to see the series because the
series is going to be hilarious cause
mayhem is never going to stop fucking
with them and I've already heard some shit
that's gone down. I can't divulge any
information to give you any previews,
but there's already been some crazy shit
going down and mayhem is having a blast.
He's a true hands. Like I'm around comics
all the time. That dude's hilarious.
Yeah, I mean he's a true
personality. He's, he's got
bigger than life personality.
He's so entertaining. Like, I love hanging
out with the guy because he's just,
it's just always fun.
He just want to get some insight into him.
Read his articles. He's smart. Yeah. He's
a good writer, man. He's a good writer.
No doubt. He's a really smart guy.
He's not, you know, you think,
are you looking at him? He's got
dyed hair. He's like, yeah, smart.
Very smart.
He's got a great take on things and a
very thought out take on things and if you
read his blogs like he works,
he's very proud of them.
He's a very good writer
and he could fucking easily
write a book and it would be
a great book because he said there's
a guy who's lived some crazy shit.
My buddy and my buddy Anthony
Tampax was a novelist who actually,
it was talking to him about his novel. He
would, he said, you should write a book,
and I think, I think he's going to call
it total mayhem or something like that.
This is great. Yeah. Why not
just tell his story, man.
These fucking stories of getting in
fights with his dad and she's growing up,
getting in fights on his blog. I
said, the first time I met him,
I were in Vegas and I walked
in and I said, dude, you know,
I've got to just be honest in a tee shirt.
You don't look that tough. I, you know,
he,
I mean besides the nose and the ears,
but you look at his back and he's a big
oven. It's Kinda lanky. I mean, if you,
if he said, I'm a, I'm a tennis
pro, I'd be like, that makes sense.
You're a tennis pro. You're
not, he doesn't look like
an MMA fight. It's not like,
uh, like, like Jake, you look in his
ears and his neck. You're like, wow.
But may him from behind
somewhat slender gig conversation. Yeah,
exactly. This is how it's done. I am,
I've been listening to you guys like
as if you guys were all gay guys,
like talking about other guys so much
louder than the steam and the steam of the
shower.
What I'm trying to say is that he tends
to just the way the water rivulets his
body was holding me down. I came here
and leave your butt fucking is so weird.
Can't believe you've got
that kind of top game.
Just don't smile at me cause then it
makes it really gay for the last five
minutes. I've been thinking about
that and you're like, you know,
like you said beautiful body.
You said you should see his,
if he gets a hold of you on
top, you know, you're like,
you just replay the whole thing.
What you're saying and act like you
were talking about other gay guys like
Gossiping. It's one of the
funniest things though. So
a psychiatrist have a field
day. First of all, you know,
it also charges to have a field day.
Talking about Jujitsu, it's two guys.
Two guys in their forties yeah.
Two guys in their forties passion.
I'm talking about fighting. One
guy has a very, very manly beer.
The other one is shaved his off and he's
got a backwards baseball hat and he's
pushing 50 cut to us an hour one.
No shirts, no shirts. I'm hot,
not going to wear these pants.
I got this new lotion I'm using. If
it's the right choice. Let me see.
How does it feel like flowers go man.
You feel as slippery as a sly.
Finally found the steep rate
of listening to MMA talk.
Now I will not have eyes
glazed over anymore.
I'll be giggling like a
mother fucker attendance.
Talking about gay sex cuts me
wearing a Bandanna for no reason.
A lot of people don't still don't
know that Brian was the one.
I had a thing called getting pumped that
a Howard stern used to play a bunch of
times.
It was on my first CD.
I'm going to be dead someday and it's me
and this other dude working out in the
basement and it's me and Brian and uh,
it was fuck that was to that.
I'm Kelly, Kirsten and Kelly
Curtis and played my mom.
I remember when we lay that down. Yeah,
that was fun, Dude. That was very fun.
Anyway,
if you ever meet may him asking him to
tell you the story about when he was in
Florida and he ended up in Jane,
like six guys.
He was dancing with a girl and guys
like you trying to disrespect me.
He was like, Nah, I'm not
disrespecting Dan. Dan A guy's eye.
He throws a punch and my based
on goes with an elbow knocks man.
I gotta get Outta here. He goes out there
and like six guys come on. He's like, Oh,
here goes, they had no idea
what they were getting into.
It's like I was just like a bunch of,
you know,
coyotes coming in on a pit
bull or something and like,
oh, it's gotta be like,
knock you out dad. I, there was a bot pile
of bodies around him. Wow. Yeah. I mean,
you want to fight him.
You're not a pro.
Just throwing a couple punches in your
life. It took some karate in high school.
Go have fun, have fun with me and Miller.
Well, this what people don't understand.
The difference between a professional
fighter on a regular human being is this
is something that doing every day,
all day for hours.
And Man doesn't take time off.
He doesn't get fat if mayhem doesn't have
a fight going on, he's still training.
He's still doing, Jujitsu is still doing
his boxing. He's still doing everything.
[inaudible] it was literally like trying
to have an argument with a guy and all
you have is a book on the
language and he's fluent in it.
[inaudible] just going to tell you
what not. That's exactly what it is.
But it's like, it's like fighting
is like a language, you know,
and everybody there you go to Fulcan
homemaker, bro. And he told you something,
you don't really actually like coming
because he's going to kick your knees out
from you and get along.
Just don't laugh and then you're gonna
realize he doesn't get tired because he's
fucking doing it for six hours a day.
I remember getting drunk with Eve Edwards
and, and, and, and, and Nate Marquardt.
We were, we were in a, we were
shooting this, um, this, uh,
movie in Pittsburgh and he started
just, this is warrior, right?
This comes out in September and, uh,
and it's been testing through the roof.
This is what you play me, I play you.
I remember I called you and I said,
I'm playing you in a movie. I called
you. I go, I'm planning in a movie.
Can you give me some advice?
He goes,
I just tried to take myself completely
out of the equation and that really
helped. I just would call the fights,
but they wrote some funny stuff from me.
I'm a, I'm a smart ass, you know, in the
movie. Nice. Nice. But I'm a rolling,
what's your name in the
movie, Brian? It really,
well, I don't know why more actors
just don't do the way I got the parts.
I put the, I put the writer
and the director together.
Imagine that Tom Hanks as stars,
as Tom Hanks do that Danny
Devito is Danny Devito.
A short twin of Arnold Schwartzenegger
played by Arnold Swartz.
And do you think Swardson nigger
is ever going to bounce back?
Do you think anybody will
ever take you guys seriously?
I don't think so.
Mainly because it depends
on how he reacts to it,
but if you're older now, first of all,
nobody wants to see him as an action hero.
Number two, you know, look, I understand
infidelity. I can understand as a man,
you f you may stray. Let's
all be respectful. Let's
all be forgiving, et Cetera.
Okay, I've net, not that I've
ever had thoughts like that,
but the point is that if you're going
to fund the housekeeper, here's it.
Just first of all, that's outrageous,
but let shit, I'll give it to you.
I don't know.
Maybe she had big tests.
She was off you and she smelled like
something. You were born. I get it.
You're the king of the world.
How about pulling up or we're in a condom?
I don't know.
How about not giving her a baby?
Think the whole thing is the wild thing.
The whole thing of doing it is you're
not even supposed to be doing this and
she's soaking your raw car.
Can you just look at that fucking
housekeeper pussies? This is my house.
I fucking everybody in my house. I
just think about it. And you did.
Should I pull out Gonan doesn't bluff.
It's shoot a load in the were like
Kona and shit. Easy. When you're, when,
when you're the king of the world, why
not? He's the king of his world, man.
The guy's living in this
$20 million mansion.
Apparently right after this happened,
they put the house up for sale
and it wasn't, he didn't know it.
He sold it to someone else.
But this is the house where all the
affairs took place and he sold it to like
some professional golfer
or something like that.
And that guy put it up right away and
he might've put it up right away because
people started hassling him
extension drive through
and fidelity, this is
echoing in the walls,
like a mass murderer building.
That building's haunted with him coming,
uh, coming all the time, calming.
Uh, and he fucked her for 10 years,
man. He did. He was fucking her for 10.
You were so excited. Oh,
I thought, oh no, no, no.
God, no, no. He was, he
was banging her in the bed.
He was how raised tagging her in the
bathroom. He was banging her every,
once you think of it as a tool
for masturbation type thing,
like she was just like a fleshlight.
Amen. What are you talking about dude?
That's a human being. Yeah, but it's
also her, his main kind of things.
He has a face.
It looks a little bit like mayhem millers
and I'm not attracted to that, but uh,
I guess he is. She was a big I, who knows
what she looked like when she was young.
I think he could make a comeback if he
doesn't maybe like cop land and whenever
you're ready.
What she looks like.
I don't mean to make fun of the
Mexican female version of Krs one.
Listen, she has a daughter.
That's all. She's a pretty
lady. That's what I'm saying.
I'm a big scare.
One Fan.
That's it sounded the police
look good for her man, but she,
she was doing what she was. No woman can
say no to our scores girl that told me.
Huh?
Do you ever see
cop land now?
Like that was kind of a weird movie for
Sylvester Stallone where it was kind of
like you played a little chubby
fat. Yeah. I think if he,
if Arnold does a movie like that where
he plays a character that's like kind of
like down on his luck coming back,
you know, kind of like a dirty cop
or something like that.
I want to see a good actor do that.
I don't know how good an actor he,
is it true?
Don't go to the movies
to see dramatic gut,
but you also thought that it festers
Stallone when he no, no, no, no,
because semesters told
him. Did Rocky. Yeah. Okay.
You got to remember he did
some shitty ass Middle East,
but Sylvester Stallone did fucking rocky
road and it's one of the best movies
hung in there because they wanted
to give that movie to someone else.
They wanted to give that movie to
some other stars and he said, no,
this is my movie.
And when he wrote this and did this,
and in the end of the movie,
he doesn't even when,
that's what a lot of people don't
even realize he loses in that movie.
It was inspired by a losing
performance by Chuck Wepner,
with Chuck Wepner Flop Muhammad Ali.
So he wrote all this shit out.
It did it all himself and acting,
it's fucking asshole.
He became a goof kind of later. And I
love him. I mean, when I say a Goof,
I'm saying a guy who does these big crazy
cartoonish movies and forget how great
those moments where when you were a
young man and I saw first blood. Yeah.
That's one of the best movies
I've ever seen. I loved it.
It was great for who you were at the time.
And at the time it came out, you know,
and being 14 or whatever,
but rocky still a bad ass fucking
yeah,
but I mean if you take away the fighting,
I haven't seen rocky maybe
10 years. No, I know,
but is the acting actually good? It's
a Talia Shire. Brilliant man. Squashed
it three days ago and, and uh,
I'll tell you something right now.
That movie holds the test of time.
It is,
it is still a lot of great movies and
one of the most moving movies when,
when he's down,
he's gonna stay down rock.
I remember Burgess Meredith when he comes,
that actor who call and he says,
I want to be a manager rock. I'm 76
years old. I want to be a man. It stinks.
You know what my place,
and he does that whole thing.
Then it comes running out and puts them.
It was such a beautiful, it's brilliant.
It was, it was the great one
of the greatest character
pieces ever written in my
opinion,
to when he's angry and he's like,
this is all he's got in his
house and in birds around there.
And he's in and he's yelling and
screaming. That was so fucking real.
And then he was so moving when
he looks at Adrian and he goes,
I remember when I said that stuff
they said about me on TV. Didn't hurt
and he walks away if your
heartbreaks for man. Yeah.
It's like when he gets his shit together
and got up and starts drinking raw eggs,
you're fucking, you start moving
your seat and you got goose bumps.
A lot of people credit, a lot
of dual credit. That movie for,
for our sharing in the
fitness craze in America.
Shortly I was whatever I was and when
it came out 11 or something like that,
I drank raw eggs and ran around my block.
Damn threw up.
I just don't remember the dude. He
was a bad motherfucker. And it's,
it's a weird thing. It's
like, wow, how does a guy,
I guess he just gives up
on good movies and says,
let's just merge something queries and
explode. I always have a good time.
But yeah, that might be a bit, I think
what happens is like with Arnold, anybody,
uh,
you
know, when you've been,
when you surround yourself,
it's almost impossible to avoid
when you surround yourself with,
with a army of people that
make their living off you.
What happens I think is that like
anything at politician has been empowered.
Too Long.
You start,
you lose self awareness because
everybody's telling you you're perfect,
you're great. They laugh at your jokes
and everything. You're the emperor.
And I think that it,
the,
the biggest trapping of that kind of fame
is that you start to drink the Koolaid
and you lose perspective. You
lose self awareness. You, you,
you keep playing the same note over and
over again because people keep telling
you it's great.
And instead of like actually putting
yourself back in the real arena,
which is competing with what's really
going on and having people really give you
real critiques, uh, you know,
I was in an acting class and Burt Reynolds
showed up and he did some scenes in
class and I thought to myself, Burt
Reynolds at 70, whatever it is,
still not only doing scenes in class,
but kind of failing in front of people
and having a teacher critique his
performance.
And was he getting a lot of white
pussy because of this young white?
I didn't see that, but that's probably
why anybody would be in an acting class.
By the way, it's Burt Reynolds
from boogie nights. So good. And so
areas, you know, he did a scene from
carnal knowledge with uh, uh, uh,
Catherine Bell from uh, anyway, but um,
well he's another guy, right?
Go back to deliverance.
Burt Reynolds was a bad motherfuckers.
He was, he was a bad motherfucker.
And then he got pain and then
he got weird. Why you start?
You start wearing a wig and
you get plastic surgery. I
don't think still though,
Dude.
Those fucking,
there's something about him and those
smokey and the bandit movies where you
really wanted him to succeed.
He was a great movie star.
He is a good looking
guy who is always happy.
They always had a smile on his face.
He had a silly mustache and he was always
getting the girl and you wanted them
to as a fucking, wanted him to get
away from the law. And by the way,
he weighed off and mustache work.
Fucking rock that.
I grew up mustache. I do this thing for
a Californication. I had a mustache.
I looked like I should work in
a deli. That's a sexy. As I get,
like I should be making sandwiches.
He looks like a fucking, you know,
a leading man. I looked like an ape. Very
hard to piss a mustache. Go. I go human.
This is what I got human here. And then
I go to AP and then I shave it down.
The human when I went with a
mustache wants just a goof.
And Mrs. Reagan was like,
what the fuck is that on your face?
It looks like a caterpillar.
Big, fat thick. I look,
I look like an aggressive
gay man who makes sandwiches.
I'm fuck guys.
And I make sandwiches in my deli.
You knew it works on Brian Jarvis.
He's not comedian Brian Jervis at all.
Brian Jarvis has eight.
Tom Selleck, my stash.
And if you'd know his comedy and he
knew his face, it's just perfect.
You say aggressive gay man.
Um,
for a while I never knew that Chrystal
myth was so popular in the gay community.
I had no idea that meth and amphetamines
and speed and an email nitrates and a
bunch of like really crazy chemicals
are so prevalent in the gay community.
So I would occasionally
run into dudes that were,
especially around West Hollywood near
the comedy store that had this weird,
crazy fucking look in their eye.
They were like really obviously gay.
I didn't know there
were hopped up on drugs.
So in my silly 25 year old
just moving to la mined out,
I was like,
wow,
there's a certain look that some of these
gay guys get when they're really crazy.
I didn't realize that there's fucking
like the hub of gay Matthews in the
country, you know, that it was
a sexual look like, oh my God,
I just thought that's what they look like.
Like it was like you, you have to have,
you have amazing radar for
anything off kilter. It's like,
it's like an animal of prey that sees
like if you put a cow in a, in a, um, uh,
not an animal print off of
the cow is an animal fray.
But like if you put an animal
of flight in like a, um,
a stall and there was a paint piece of
like a string hanging that it hasn't seen,
they won't go in that stall and
you have a very good eye for,
for something that's like
that sharp f like there's,
there's music and all of a sudden somebody
comes in with a horn, like, ma'am,
you know, you're like, ah,
that's something you pick up on that
stuff better than anybody. I know
I grew up without anybody protecting me.
So I grew up in some weird
situations and you know,
we lived in a bunch of places where I
didn't have any friends and I was forced
at a very early age to try to kind of
like get an objective sense of the world
around me without listening
to other people's opinions
of it, without, you know,
taking for granted that everyone else is
paying attention and that they've got a
grip on reality. To me, no
one had a grip on reality.
So I'm always like scanning everything.
And when I,
and I'm an honest person so when I see
someone there's, there's something off.
When I see something off it's literally
like it smells to me and I always use
two examples.
One,
I use the one with the girl with you
when I met and this is a true story.
She's crazy.
You've got to get out of here right now.
She's crazy and it wasn't just,
I wasn't just saying that
this is maybe a crazy girl.
I was like emphatic about
it. It was cheese hot tab.
I'm out and I didn't know it.
She was doing meth and but I chose
to move her into house anyway,
but that's where it comes from.
And the other one was this guy that
turned out to be a child molester and my
friend would, yon was on the
podcast couple of weeks ago.
We talked about it where I met the guy
know right away they're hanging out with
this guy. Like he's their friend,
their buddy and right away I'm like,
what the fuck is this guy doing
here? What do it, this was like,
everything was like all
these alarms are going off.
He calls me up a couple
of weeks later and goes,
you're not going to believe who just got
arrested. And he says that guy's name.
Like, oh, he was a child child molester,
right? And he goes, yeah. He goes,
how the fuck did you know? I go, dude,
I don't know. I don't know how I knew.
But that was number one gas. I mean,
when you were younger, you met this guy,
you know? No, no, no, this
is just a few years ago.
But those are my two best examples of
coming in and just pick up right away.
I saw him and right away I was like, what
the fuck? And I even said to the guy,
what's up with that guy? What
was it? I Dunno man. It was,
everything smells the way he's moving,
the way he was interacting with other
people like young kids, penis. Well,
so when you say smell stuff,
when you say smell,
that's a thing that they
believe about psychosis,
about some psychotic behavior may
actually may actually be triggered by
pheromones.
And
literally you put out a certain smell
and this is all theoretical and you know,
they really don't exactly know like what
causes some people psychotic episodes,
but they think you put out a certain
smell and then people smell this and
they're put off by you. And so people
are acting weird with you. So you think,
am I weird?
And it starts this chain reaction that
literally can make a person slash go
crazy. You know, we know.
And we know when you,
the worst thing you can do to a person
in prison is to put them in solitary
confinement and leave them
alone with their own thoughts,
without interacting with sample.
So the psychosis is actually forms.
Yeah,
there's something that we need when we
interact with people and when we get it
wrong.
Like if you literally smell off and I'm
using the word smell because there's a
smell like that,
there's a real pheromones are like,
you don't really smell it right.
Vibrate at the wrong frequency there.
They're jerking differently there and
your body, there's a good book. I mean,
Malcolm Gladwell wrote that book, Blink
about that, where you pay you a human.
I can pick up a massive amount of
information. Did you, did you ever hear,
do you ever read that book?
He uses? An amazing example
of there was this, uh, this,
uh,
the Getty Museum paid a fortune,
a fortune for a statute
that was a young Greek boy.
It was called a Kudos and they found the
statute in Greece fully formed and they
were like, Whoa, this is, this
statue is like, I mean, they,
they had never found something and
it was worth a fortune. And again,
he was going to pay something like
33, $100 million, some crazy amount,
$30 million, whatever it is. And
it was a lot of money. And so, but,
but the thing is the Getty kept running
these tests on it. And this guy,
the guy who was a career
writer and people,
the first thing that came to his
mind, he said, when I saw it,
there was something off. I
said, what was it? He said,
the first word that came to mind was
fresh when I started. It looked fresh.
He said, and if it's something's
been in the ground for 5,000 years,
it shouldn't come out looking fresh.
So they ran all these tests.
They dug into the marble really, really
deep. They, they, they took the fung,
the mold on the actual
marble to see how old it was.
And they did all these tests and they,
I mean,
literally spent a year testing
it before they bought it. Okay.
So now they buy it and
they put it on display.
I believe they brought it to
Italy to or to show at this big,
there was a traveling
exhibit, exhibit, you know,
and the minute they were setting it
up to show as they pulled it off,
I believe the, and if you guys are
listening and you read the book, I, I,
it's been a while since I read the books.
So, but for the art, for the story,
say the curator of that museum,
the guy who's the expert,
they lifted the veil to show
how they're going to present it.
And he's after all these tests and he
stopped anyway. He goes, w w w this,
did you guys pay for this already? And
I go, yeah, what are you talking about?
Oh No, no. Can you get your money back?
No, no, no. This is a fake. This is fake.
And I go, what are you talking
about? And he picked up on it.
He picked up on what everybody
else picked up on it. But they,
but they were so excited that they
actually found this thing that they didn't
want to believe it.
And he said,
if you have to test for a year
on the authenticity of something,
all of you guys all have
your experience minds.
We're telling you right away there's
something wrong here. And he goes,
Ms. But he uses so many
classic examples why watch
this? When he had, they had,
they had people come to his office to a
psychiatrist's office and they would, um,
when they mentioned the words orange,
Florida and raising people left the office
much slower than they did otherwise.
Why?
Because when you mentioned orange,
Florida and raising people
thought of old people, retirees.
And so young people would
actually leave the office.
They would walk down the hallway
leaving the office much slowly,
a lot slower than they did when they
didn't hear those words. So what you hear,
what, what is suggested to you has a
profound effect on your physiology,
not just your mind. And he was his
so many incredible examples of this.
I can't even tell you it's, it's
incredible. So if you guys have,
if you guys are listening, the book
is called Blink and it's outstanding.
All of Malcolm Gladwell's
books.
So this guy in the,
literally a blink of an eye saw this
statue and new immediate Felton and the
human eye,
the human eye can,
you can glance at something
and pick up on everything,
much more information
than you can even imagine.
And we have learned how to do that.
It's called, um, he calls it slicing,
I think broad slicing or something
where you just, you know, pick up.
I've always felt like there's
more sentences than we can
totally defined because
there's a sense when someone's lying.
There's a sense that it's very difficult
to describe deceptive like language.
Because if you looked at it on a computer,
the timing seems to be pretty similar.
I mean, if someone's good at it, yeah,
they're timing is pretty similar
to the someone who's being
lie detector do it measures in a
very minute detail. Your breathing,
your respiratory rate,
all of these things,
the heat of your skin and
all that and that, that,
that changes when you're not
telling the truth. I've always,
well, unless you're a sociopath,
if that goes off though,
if you're nervous because you
ever been innocent of something,
but someone thinks you're guilty and
when you're describing what actually
happened,
it sounds ridiculous and you feel
like you're guilty or not guilty does.
But a good a guy who knows
Britta lie detector it, we'll,
we'll take that into account.
And that's why when you do that,
they ask you very simple questions.
First they asked me, what's your name,
what, where'd you grow up? And you,
and then they'll start getting
into it slowly. Um, and they,
then they take that into account.
Now a lot of guys telling you,
you can throw off a lot of tech test by
getting your body tight to begin with.
And you said you fool it so you yeah,
get him to stay high as fuck. I don't
know. I bet you sociopath on Lsd.
It just blazed through
them with sociopath's.
Apparently it doesn't work because they
don't care cause I don't care. No guilt.
You would think though,
you could easily throw it off by just
like every time he asks you a question and
you just think of something
like my dog dying.
Yeah, that's what they get. They can force
you out of that. There's, there's like,
they know that people do that.
So there's tactics in order to like to
trip you up with questions are Kinda will
fuck with your emotions cause you don't
know what the questions are going to be
beforehand. So yeah, I know
what you're saying though.
I would think that to think about
Spiderman every time they ask you,
have you ever stole money from this bank?
You think about spider.
Yeah.
Like razor blades in your ass and it hurts
so bad the whole time you're thinking
about the reason I say
razor blades in their ass.
Oh Brian, there's a thing that
I wanted to talk about this.
You were talking about that,
um, that statute being a fraud,
there's a thing called
the Voynich manuscript.
I don't know if you ever
known or heard about this,
but it was a book that was thought to
have been written in the early 15th
century and uh, it's in a language
that no one could decipher.
And they, uh, they sent this to the,
all the top coders and the experts
and the people that you know,
decoded the Nazi signals in the, in the
forties and the top coders in the world.
And people have gone over it for decades.
Nobody can figure out
how to fucking decode it.
They have no idea what
this language is they have,
it's all like illustrated with
all these beautiful pictures.
But nobody wanted to admit that since
they had been working on this for so long,
it might just be bullshit.
And that's what it turns out to this.
It turns out that this is a, a guy,
they think the guy that sold it,
and Nigel initially to this
void, each fellow was a, um,
a con man and that he knew that Voynich
loved old manuscripts so he can cocked
it. This really elaborate old
manuscript, completely detailed, uh,
pictures of plants and all
these different things.
So it makes it look like there's
all sorts of knowledge in this book,
but it's hundred percent horseshit,
a fake language.
And he wrote a 205th 40 page fake language
book and people have been studying it.
So shit since fucking when did
it get it? 1912. Incredible.
1912.
So for a hundred fucking years,
assholes have been going over this guy's
fake book and people is suspected it.
Early on people were like, well,
what if it's a [inaudible]? No, no.
And the more time goes on,
the more they don't want to even think
about the possibility that could have
been a fake. Yeah. It's kind of like
that. That's very human. It's very human.
Yeah. And this story, it's the been the
beginning of the book is just incredible.
Will you just say,
wow,
the Getty got duped by a comment and you
know what they found the, uh, the, the,
the, the mold on the, uh, on
the, uh, cause it was taken
from out from a type of um,
uh,
a type of marble that can only be found
in a rock bed and like Thessaloniki or
like one of these like, so that guy,
the came from there and, and the, the,
the mold, they have these tests that
test the mold and how old it was. They,
there's a type of mold that grows on
a potato that you can grow on marble.
So whoever did this knew exactly
what they were doing. Wow.
And they just got away with 30, 40,
whatever million dollars to the,
at the Getty calming, just cut,
disappearing. People are such bad ass.
It's like talk about just
calling all the way, like, yeah,
found the statute because
you want to buy it.
Like even coming up with that
like, hey guys, I've got an idea.
Let's carve a statue out of marble.
In the rock bed of Thessaloniki and
we'll grow a potato mold on itself.
A 40 minute get the fuck out of my office.
What?
Somebody must have a really known
a lot about art to pull that off.
That's what blows my mind.
There are people out there that are just
so good at stuff like that and that's
how they do it. They just, they just
hang the cut and they go, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna rip off a museum. All the
experts in the world. Yes it is.
It's a movie shit.
It's like you heard about that
Lee Martin Lee Marie Heist.
Oh yeah, the fighter MMA fighter
from England million dollars.
Something like it was in pounds.
I don't
know how it translates, but you'll
fight around a bank robber in the space.
It was like the biggest heist in
history. She let him out. Come on.
They were masks and guns and
they literally like planned
it all out and timed it
all out to the alarms.
They did it like a goddamn movie and he's
in a jail in Morocco and Morocco won't
send them back over.
Morocco's Morocco is pretty looked
out like if you're a Moroccan citizen,
they protect you was a bit a few fighters
that got in trouble and just bolted to
Morocco.
Like Badr Hari,
Hari gotten a bit of travel bolted
to Morocco once you're Morocco, man,
they kicked take care of their own.
So they love fighters in Morocco,
but leemary man,
he just fucked up too large.
They had to come after him even in
Morocco and when he was in Morocco,
by the way, on the lamb, he beat a
guy up and kidnapped him. Oh my God.
Rock God. He wasn't slowing
down. He got to [inaudible].
I had a feeling he runs that prison yard.
Oh, he's an animal. Yeah. That guy was a,
he's quite a character.
That guy got almost stabbed to death.
He got stabbed like some
insane amount of times.
His heart stopped a couple times.
They had to restart them on the fucking
operating table and he had a video
online of him six to eight weeks
I think after open heart surgery,
hitting the pads,
he's,
he then the like lean Mary's
back and chose Lean Mary.
They like bobbing and weaving and
throwing combinations in the pads to six
fucking weeks after open heart surgery.
We are flight. I'm going to take a nap.
I'm tired. I wish I know the
exact amount of weeks it was.
It might not have been six,
it might have been 12 whatever it was.
It was fucking ridiculous. This guy had
just had open heart surgery. Nelson,
he's hitting the pants and he's
getting ready to fuck people up.
That's when he's saying, he's like,
I'm back. You fucking bitches.
He's thrown a punch.
The pads,
like this guy was getting hard with
a knife and I'll still kick your ass.
He's a legit gangster. He's, that guy
was legit originally from England. Well,
he lived in England and lived in,
fought out of England.
Flotsam tough guys to man fought Anderson
Silva went the distance with them. Wow.
And Anderson was a really coming into
his own as when Anderson came the cage
rage craze. Anybody pull off? Huge
high. A very good question, man.
A Guy just pulled off a fucking Picasso
Heist in San Francisco because it's
different though,
because the art is a really good thing
to get into because first of all,
jury is considered it
like a victimless crime.
So a lot of times you don't do a lot
of time. And also there's always,
and also there's just people
that that you can unload it with.
It's an interesting story that this one,
this guy walked into a gallery,
picked it up off the wall, walked
out, got in a cab, took off.
Nobody noticed him taking this
Picasso sketch off a wall. Wow,
that's worth like 200 grand.
And he just grabs it and leaves.
But the thing is like, good luck selling
it. How are you going to sell that thing?
Everyone knows what it is. You know
what I mean? You're constantly,
there's private sellers. I'm
really rich, Jeff Cha Cha,
Chinese tycoon who lives like you know in
Manchuria and Watson on his wall. Yeah.
You would have to know
exactly who that guy is.
That's like a tricky situation that
Picasso for sale give me a hundred grand.
Yeah,
but that's how you get caught though
too. You know, they sell it me. Well,
you got to let the guy who's selling
it make a big, big piece of the Pie.
That's what you've got to do.
If you've got something like
that and stolen and you're smart,
what you would do is he would go
to someone and say, listen man,
we both know this thing's worth 200 grant.
Give me a hundred you know, it's funny,
you take a hundred grand off of
it, and then the guy's like, okay,
well I just made a good
fucking chunk of money.
Now this is worth my risk and I
can ensure both of our safety's,
but I don't think criminals, I
don't, couldn't think criminal. I'm,
I'm like a gentleman
criminal. Yeah, exactly.
I don't think criminals like
that do it for the money.
I think criminal charge and you know,
we all have,
some people have to get drunk.
Some people have to get, you know,
they have to do blow. Other people just
have to do crime. It's the same guy.
I'd recommend Jujitsu. My friends
get in there and get your freak on.
I start rolling and get back in there.
Buddy Javier victims,
who have you ever heard of him is,
I'm half a mile away.
His brother going there, but hey, it's
Javier here. Javier is his brother.
That's like,
you know for is not that big a deal man.
I'm telling you I haven't
got the real deal.
I gave him an award at the MMA
awards at Fau February's here.
He is such a giant is a huge dude.
He's just a huge guy.
He's a bad ass Jujitsu guy.
If this was just Jujitsu,
if MMA was just Jujitsu like it,
see he's one of those guys that really
became an MMA fighter as a Jujitsu
champion and had to learn everything
else from scratch. And you're like,
when you first like first
fought all Lawsky like you
look at that fight like had
no striking. Even when he fought Alastar
the first time had very little strike.
Yeah. He just wanted to get guys
to the ground and when he got out,
started the ground back then
he submitted them. Yeah.
It's a shame that there's not like
professional Jujitsu and professional
wrestling. Yeah, but there's not real
money and it, you know what I mean?
I mean like, and wrestling as well,
man, like real professional wrestling.
It should be a game. To me,
that's a very small audience who,
I'm going to say that, but fucking golf
is on TV, man. That's boring as fuck.
If you know, you could watch like
real, like high level wrestlers,
all that.
You can't tell me that if you didn't
get someone to explain it correctly,
you get some really passionate wrestling
champion guide. Explain it correctly.
Almost think that people would
watch wrestling did wrestle.
So they know the difference.
I don't know about that man.
I think people could watch it. Just
like, I swear to God, I could watch golf.
I know it's boring as fuck, but I
can watch it. There's a conclusion.
I know what their conclusion is.
This guy's going to hit that thing.
And if it's going, it goes
in there, then he's happy.
And if it doesn't go in there, oh,
he's fucked. You know what I mean?
So in that simple little,
I don't play golf and I don't
know what strokes on power.
You should never pick up golf
because you'll become quicker.
I'm going to touch it. But you're,
you're so, you're so obsessive outside.
You'll love it. I can't do
it. Well I wouldn't do it.
Well that's what I always think about.
Like when, why would you play pool?
You know, like if it was outside,
wouldn't he make it all inside?
That'd be ridiculous because then he
could play in the rain. Like Golf,
you can't play in the rain.
Like especially in the
east coast. They're like,
I know when you get an addiction you
don't want to have to take the time off.
In the winter. I played pool
all through the winter. You
know, you can always, yeah,
you can still play in the rain.
And that's what kind of makes it different
than pool is that your environment's
always changing. So it's not like the
same flat surface every time you're like,
hey,
now the pool table,
it's like you're in a mountain and
there's an ocean in the middle of it,
you know? That is cool. And it
also is cool that you have to adjust
for like the wind and shit like that.
I think about like you're playing against
nature a little bit office is that
saying it's like they're the
longest distances that one,
the one the distance between your ears,
you know it's all mental.
So as his pool pool is,
what you're doing with pool is you
are have a slippery surface of a fast
Simona's eight 60 cloth, right? It's, it's
not even like felt. People think of it,
it's felt,
but it's a cloth and the balls roll very
nice and smooth and even on that and
the balls are all waxed and cleaned and
they all weighed the perfect amount of
weight. They all weigh the same
exact weight and these balls,
you're colliding one ball into another
trying to send it into a very small
space. You know, usually in
pro tournaments it's four
and a half inch pockets.
So you have very little room for error
and you're calculating the exact distance,
the amount of rotations that ball's going
to make on this slip cloth to get your
ball in the perfect
position for the next shot.
And it becomes this weird zen thing.
Do you know, on, on that speaking of balls
colliding into each other? Um, you know,
you know what,
that,
that collider actually that's super
collider in Switzerland accident.
You know what it actually does, you
know what they're trying to figure out?
The Higgs Boson particle? Yeah. The
God particle. Well, when we are,
well actually they're that they're
trying to prove that Spring Siri,
this notion that there are other
dimensions where matter goes, right.
And so when they collide these
things together, it within this,
this chamber,
when these two atoms I guess,
or is that what the [inaudible] gonna
hit them at? And they, when they,
when they collide, they give off
to debris. They give off energy.
If that energy goes away,
if part of that energy kind of doesn't,
isn't there anymore with that would
prove that those tiny particles that are,
that are made actually smaller than
quarks are going somewhere else and that's
how they're trying to prove
that there are other dimensions.
Yeah, but does that even make sense?
Like what of those article burnout,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like I know they said that energy can
never die or whatever. And if, if those,
that those particles go
into another dimension,
but what if those particles just died?
You know what?
We were just wrong about that.
I don't know. Here's why. Here's
why. Because particles can,
the two things can happen.
There's the answer.
There's a lot of confusion when it
comes to subatomic particles and when it
comes to any kind of quantum theory,
because it gets started,
it gets kind of culty and weirdy
and it sort of gets a lot.
A lot of it is theoretical,
but here's what they do know.
They do know that particles can exist
and not exist. At the same time.
They can be in two different places
at the same time and they're the same
particle and they can disappear and
reappear and we don't know where they're
going.
But there they do go somewhere and that
seems to indicate a level of evidence at
least some in infants,
Massimo subatomic level that there is
some sort of a a passage way where where
things go from one place and come back.
String theory is that based on on this
notion that these, that,
that at the end of it,
the very smallest particles are all of
these sort of vibrating circles of light
and those are so small that
they can fit into different,
different I guess of where,
and the idea behind string theory is
that you have the Newtonian reality which
is the reality you and I live in,
which is gravity and everything else.
And then you have the Subatomic,
a reality which is,
which is whenever you get into
sub atomic and subatomic world,
a lot of times the very laws that
govern us are in fact the opposite.
Light Bends,
gravity collapses on itself.
All these things I don't know about but
I mean they'll talk about string theory
is the, is is what Einstein
called this unification theory.
This one thing that brings all of it
together so that you have one theory that
can explain how the world really works.
There's still a lot of controversy
with it. Yeah. Imagination. Yeah,
but they,
but they are proving with math,
with with mathematics is a very
good lecture on it and Ted but,
but they're proving with they can
prove with math that there are um,
that there are
oh 11 dimensions, 11 dimensions, no
idea of the fuck they prove it. I don't,
someone says that I just repeated, oh
they proved it with math. But you know
the answer to that,
that theory that,
that question they were coming up
with the answer was 357 pages long.
All numbers.
It looks like fun reading.
She's a school talking about,
it's like anything else man.
It's like what we discussed when we were
talking about fighting and MMA fighter
is literally like trying
to get an argument with
someone and all you have is a
language book.
Like for the average person,
they speak a different language or speak
the language of mathematics and they've
been speaking this language for decades
and decades and they go deep, deep,
deep into the rabbit hole.
It's all well cause it's cause cause the
mathematical theory it was where you go
is it is all imagination.
You know, you see these guys,
they're actually really like,
you know this one dude is working on that.
The particle collider.
It gave this lecture at Ted Young,
really good looking kid like dressed
like with these awesome clothes and just
kind of like cheese. You don't get laid
Dhea and, and, and, and yet he says
brilliant businesses
like brilliant physicist,
physicist sort of have a
history of being skirt chasers.
If you go back to Fineman, those like
one of fireman's, there was like,
there was like a bubble chart that would
be like our girls around if no girls
around, you know, here's
where it comes. Physics.
Here's what's great about that is that
I'm not that smart and I have nothing to
talk to girls about. For the most part.
I wonder what those guys have. Fine,
but it was just such a genius.
I mean, he was just, he was so,
he was such a good talker too,
and he had like kind of a cool accent
too because even though he was a genius,
he had a very sort of an ethnic east coast
accent, which is really odd. This guy,
this guy who I'm talking about, he's
from Manchester and she talks like that,
you know, and he's not, he's unbelievable.
He's got long black hair and he wears
this great sort of, you know these fast.
I'm like, dude, you accent. You got,
you got hair like Johnny Depp and you're
off your and you can help build that
collider. You're one of the leading
minds in your 28 no, my father guys,
Aubrey de grey.
Do you know who he knows?
He's the guy who's trying to make people
live forever and he has this incredible
Maine. Oh, I know exactly what that all
drinks. I'm here like every day. Yeah,
he's awesome. He's amazing. Did you know
Ray Kurzweil now has transcendent man?
He came out without, yeah,
there's a documentary.
We've talked about it
a hundred it's a bread.
I love that guy with that long beard.
He's like,
awesome. People can live forever.
Yeah, well he's fucking on the cusp.
I mean that guy is at the
head of, you know, the,
all the creative ideas about genetic
engineering and you know, fucking crazy.
Redoing Oregon's, you know,
they, they created a windpipe
recently with stem cells.
Did you see that as an artist? What I
took out? Yeah. Well they, I think they,
what they did is they took a,
a cadaver's wind pipe and sprayed it with
stem cells and grew over the cartilage.
Yeah. Which is like, okay, cool.
And then they installed it and the
guy's neck and now he can breathe. Yup.
And they didn't say anything with the
bladder's just at the beginning of some
really smart guy, I can't
remember his name. And he went,
we've not invented anything. I tell
people that and they don't understand.
Nothing's been invented yet. Just
wait for the next 40 years. Oh yeah,
you're around for the next century.
It's going to fuck everything. You know,
out the window.
I put up with something on my Twitter
yesterday about a three d printer and it
was on a television show.
There was a video of it on live
leak and this three d printer,
this guy takes a wrench and they put
the wrench into a copier and the copier
looks at the ranch and figures out how
the wrench is built and then makes it out
of resin.
Big Set of this incredibly hard resin
where you can actually use it as a fucking
wrench.
So this thing literally physically made
this wrench with moving parts and prints
it all in one piece.
That's so genius.
You know how a wrench has that thing in
the middle where you have to screw it
with your thumb to adjust it? Yeah. Well,
it made that all in one printing and
it made that part that screws what?
Your thumb a different color. So the
adjustment wheel was a different color.
It was red and the rest of the thing
was gray and it printed it in one,
three d form. It's fucking incredible.
You just tweeted that video.
Yeah. Yeah. Just what, that's
why, you know, you can, uh,
you can talk about magic technology is
way more incredible than any kind of
magic you can think of. I
mean, it is magic. I mean
that's probably what magic is.
All these stories of magicians,
it's probably just they came upon some
fucking idiots. It didn't have fire yet.
You know,
they came upon some dummies,
you didn't have guns and they had bank
sticks and they fucking just dominated
shit. That's it. Yeah. I mean look what
fucking magic would everybody forgot it.
They remember everything else.
I like that.
If we got all the magic and transcendent
man where they were talking about
basically that we are going
to mesh with machines,
there's no question and our biology is
going to die off as you make eyes that
work better as you make skin that
can heat up as you make, you know,
your body's going to start meshing with
bio compatible components that mimic and
are in fact better than the very
material you currently live in.
And,
and it's going to be a world where people
are going to decide to go that way or
the people who decide,
you know what I'm going to die like with
my old biological self of it's going to
be interesting. It's going to be
interesting to figure out what,
what would people choose to fight very
though about that movie is just the story
about him and his father.
Right? Right. Yeah.
Man recreated that was about a guy who
really misses his father and he doesn't
accept death.
Yeah.
Well that's suspicious thing
except the people that fuck bucket.
I'm going to something where they
don't. You're like, yeah, well it was,
it was obviously to him it really like
defined him as a human.
Yeah.
I loved his father and you know
that's the same story with that guy,
Ronald Mallet, the professor out
of the University of Connecticut,
that's the leading
theorist on time travel.
It's father died when he was a kid
and it freaked him out so bad that he
dedicated his life to developing a time
machine because he wants to go back in
time and saves all man. If that
doesn't make you want to fucking cry.
And this guy's like, no, he's in his
fifties and he was like the leading.
And not only that,
he's figured out it at least theoretically
through his studies that that would
actually be impossible and that what's
going to happen with the time machine,
that the current theory is that
when a time machine is invented,
what the issue becomes is then all time
ceases to become linear because everyone
from the invention of that time machine
on to the end of time can come back to
that moment in time and any moment
in between. And anytime they choose.
So time loses all of its linear quality,
but only the moment the doors opened.
That's when it happens.
So literally the, the,
the idea is that the way they describe
it as you can't travel where there are no
roads once the road has been created from
that moment in time on time ceases to
become what we define as time today.
You know, I, I had a Einstein's
theory of gravity and, and,
and they explained to me,
well like, well for example,
it's not as 93 million miles
away from the earth. Why does it,
why does it have an effect?
Why does it, why is it gravity?
It's gravity effect the
earth and so on and so forth.
Why does the moons have the same
relationship with the earth?
And the way I sent him scrap,
it was really interesting.
He said time and space bends,
it bends according to whatever
object is essentially in it.
So if you look at time
and space as a blanket,
a tight blanket and you
drop a pool ball on it,
what happens to the blanket is
there's an indentation then. So,
so that's essentially what
it's doing to time and space.
It's bent that plane of time and space.
That's a way, wild way of looking at it.
Now it's spinning.
Now take another ball.
The smaller ball is rotating within
around that because it's, it's,
it's created an indentation
there and its own orbit. So your,
so that little ball is now
going around the, you know,
the perimeter of where that one
ball is sitting. It creates a board.
And that's how Einstein described
gravity to a four year old. He said,
this is how gravity and time works.
And uh,
and of course the farther
away you get from that,
the less you spin or the longer it
takes to complete one revolution,
which means then that you get, as you go
farther away, you know, you come, you,
you don't age as quickly. I mean time goes
by much slower. That's right. That is,
it takes them longer. Why to, it takes
him longer to evolve around whatever,
whatever is exerting gravity on you.
But isn't that
crazy thought that you could escape
gravity and live longer? Yeah.
Technically you would live longer.
That's right. And when you would,
oh my God,
I have to go out
relative like to for you,
like what I'm saying is if you went out
and you were 30 years at the speed of
light and then you came
back and everyone was dead,
the people that were children were
old people. You would be the same age,
but you would feel like you would only
lived 30 years or whatever the fuck it
was. You wouldn't feel like
you've gone through, no.
You would probably a hundred
years be real for you,
I guess in your time in
30 years time. Sure. What,
how does that fucking word moving slower?
Like what's going on? You're actually,
if you're, if you're c because I
as you as take the, take the uh,
the,
the sheet and then take the ball
that's in the middle of the sheet.
As you rotate around that ball,
if you're close to that ball,
it takes, you know, it's a smaller
circle, isn't it? As you get out farther,
it's like a record player.
Take a record player.
If I put you on on the first line,
it's going to take you a much shorter
time to make a complete revolution.
I put you at the end of the record player
is going to take you a long time to
call it rally round. That's
time. And as you go further out,
it takes you much longer to
complete a year. You're, it's a,
it's a really wild concept but,
but that is where time and space bends.
So that's where my feeble brain loses
its short circuiting because one reason
why I'm losing it is because why is it
take more time when you're out further?
When in the earth I time it going faster.
I understand that there's revolutions,
but why are you not aging and feeling
the same thing as those people on earth?
If it's,
it's like I can't,
the idea of alternate versions of time
and in space traveling at a speed,
it's too much.
What's amazing though is that it's,
it's been proven with
subatomic. Um, um, uh,
when Einstein came up with these theories,
we didn't have atomic clocks and things.
We didn't have the
actual tools to prove it.
And it wasn't until later on when we
actually came up with the technology and
the math to prove it,
especially the instruments to measure it
and when we can't with the instruments
of measurement later on, say 30 40 years
later, it turned out the guy was right.
You know? That's when you know
you're really smart when you're like,
I've got a theory.
You guys don't actually even have
the machines to measure this,
but here's how it goes. Madison
being the first guy to be like, ah,
if I shoot your way out, time, time
and space bends like a blanket.
Let me show you what this pool ball, and
he'd be like, what the fuck this guy's,
what's what the gray haired guy.
Fuck.
All I'm thinking about is banging girls
and what's, that's when he was in it too,
you know, kind of a pimp.
Einstein and Picasso said,
a man does everything for women. He
fights bulls, he does it all. He Paints,
fuck it.
He goes to war for women so he can
look good and come back with a bunch of
metals on his chest. I'm not saying
that's the case with everybody.
It's amazing how guys like Einstein
and guys like Nikola Tesla,
they live amongst you and I,
but they literally couldn't be any
further from the type of person,
especially you and die. You and I
are like mirror images of each other.
We always have been our whole lives. It
was like what I'm, when I first met Brian,
it was on mad TV with his companies,
got rid of it and a, I was like,
who's this fucking guy was just
was like immediately was like, we
were the same age. We're both
ridiculous. We were both like,
we can't believe I'm in fucking
Hollywood. I'm on a TV show. I'd be like,
I can't believe I'm on a fucking
TV show either. Where are you from?
Do you know why? You know? I
got along with really well.
I just did a show of hands and
I really liked with Jay Moore.
Jamie and I hit it off right
away. He loves you. He was
talking, he's a great guy.
He's a, he's a, he's an east
coast, so smart ass felt so
comfortable with the guy.
He's such a, he looked in my ears
as good. So you wrestle. I go, yeah.
And he used to wrestle. I didn't
know that. Oh really? Yeah,
he was a wrestler and he's
just, he's funny man. He kills
me. He's a funny guy, man.
He's a silly goose. Yeah, he's a
sort of a talked about you guys,
guy sort of a comedian.
He loves you.
He lot of comics don't like
him because of that. You know,
they don't like that jockey sense
of humor. He's a great guy. Yeah.
He gets shit for that. I've heard
that about him. You know, some comp,
they don't let that hold Jame or style.
They should lift weights and take some
test task. Stop being fucking UNAMERICAN.
Cause Jim Morris a good
American on the merge.
Have you been following this marijuana
thing that they just released the reports
on? I the MED medical, yeah.
The federal government has declared
there's no medical, no. Uh,
I forget the wording,
but no valid medical use for marijuana,
which is his fucking ridiculous.
We have a friend that has a,
a brother that has, he's on the
autism spectrum. I mean, he, uh,
he communicates with you. He's, you
know, he's right there, he's present,
but he's very,
very shy.
And you give this kid pot and
you can noticeably see him relax.
And it's been known to
alleviate a lot of, uh, the,
the social anxiety and the, the, the,
the weirdness that autistic people
having communication it with
my own eyes.
I've seen it,
I've seen that very same
example of somebody who was
a high functioning autistic
who would smoke weed and would literally
become lucid. And so, you know,
you can say what you want. It's a chemical
that's going to affect your brain.
Maybe some people that affects
them negatively, other people,
it's gonna affect them positive.
But, you know, Eh, if you're gonna,
if you're gonna tell me that,
if you look at the amount of damage just
in money terms and by the way in lives
that alcohol does versus we'd,
one of the funniest,
craziest things that make no sense that
weeds illegal, but, but I'll call I, I,
okay. It's crazy. I mean it's it,
it's terrible the first person
to talk about this, but yeah,
or exactly what I mean.
It's,
it's an example of how slowly
in some ways things change.
They change very slowly
because when people get ideas,
ideas have ideas or really what move and
change everything in the world and it
goes back to these guys like Tesla.
When you think about people who were
thinking of truly seminal ideas,
like somebody will sit around and they
fucking just sit around and think like up
new constructs.
They change everything that we,
they change everything for the next
hundred years. What a privilege.
What an amazing accomplishment. Like what
an amazing accomplishment I'm going to,
I'm going to come up with,
I'm going to change everybody.
Everybody in the world's paradigm,
I'm going to change you live the
rest of your life. That's what,
that's what it is.
Well,
with these guys at the large Hadron
collider and doing her literally changing
our interface with reality.
Yeah. I mean they, they, they
have a new kind of matter.
You know this cork gluon plasma
shit that they came up with.
One sugar cube was like 40 billion tons.
I mean they're doing things that people
have only theorized for the longest time
and it's never going to stop.
This is what I tell people,
and I joke around about this on stage,
that we're here to make the big bang
and this is like a whole bit about the
large Hadron collider.
They might be like the destiny of
human beings to reset the universe.
We will never stop. Whatever we
learned from the large Hadron Collider,
we will apply to the next greater thing
because it's going to keep going on and
if we survive 100 years,
the exponential increase of technology,
you just used the word, it's exponential.
It will be national development.
It'll be beyond our imagination.
We were not,
we cannot fathom a reality that will
be so far removed from the one that we
currently experience. Right.
That's good. That's fun.
From what I understand what
that marijuana think. No,
this is actually the third time this
has happened where the US government has
said no,
this,
there's nothing good with this shit ya
and but it's a good for us because now we
can take it to the courts or whatever
the federal court or and and go against
everything they say.
So like if they say no,
this doesn't help headaches and we can
like put the proof up like no, it does.
Here's 5,000 scientists. So this is
actually a good thing that they did this.
It's very obvious that
the system is rigged.
The only reason why people would be going
after marijuana in this day and age,
we're wasting any resources on something
that kills nobody is they're getting
paid to do it. It's really
simple. You have to follow
the money. There's, there's no
money. Anytime you pass any kind of law,
cottage industry grows up around it.
There was an article that was a big
debate about ethanol today and there's an
ethanol lobby lobby and ethanol,
ethanol problems. I don't know,
you got to quote a lot of corn
and it's not that efficient.
It's not that economical.
It's proven to be not.
We've got only 10 million cars on
the road that actually are flex fuel
compatible,
which means basically a 5% of the cars
on the road right now in the United
States and and yet you have
a lobby and ethanol lobby.
You have 30 plants. Try getting rid
of ethanol. Go ahead. Good luck.
The whole lobby thing man is always
freaked me the fuck out that that's legal
and that no one ever says
anything constitutional
Ander under this you,
the reason you have lobbyists and you
always have had lobbyists is because in
the constitution you have
the right to petition your
government. The the, the, the,
the reason lobbying comp,
the reason lobbying has become such
a force and the reason politicians
essentially are beholden to the NRA and
these kinds of people is essentially
because whenever you create,
as the government becomes
bigger and has more influence,
which is what it's going to do as it
grows, regardless of what side right?
Left is not a right and left to argument.
If something like this gets bigger,
you are going to have industry that
that is going to find a way to influence
that power structure.
How do you do it?
You hire people who have
contacts with the government.
Either they work for the administration,
whatever might be,
but that's what happens.
So now you have,
now you have a county like
Potomac in, in, in uh, Maryland,
which is one of the richest I think is
probably the third richest county in the
world. Do you think they manufacturer
anything now? You know what they are?
They're all government lobbyists.
Isn't that amazing? When my,
when when you try to go from Potomac
to uh, Washington DC to the capitol,
you'll be in the car for about two
hours and it's about 20 miles away or
whatever it is. It's a parking lot.
Why? Because they're producing anything.
Are they producing things? You and I can
use nat. You know what they're doing.
It's a machine.
It is a group of people from all different
kinds of industries that live there
24,
seven and do whatever they
can to influence their
congressmen in their state.
That's how it works, baby. And so, so
when you start talking about government,
understand,
I've said this before,
I always say regardless of what
side of the aisle you're on,
government has two functions
to pass laws and to end to tax.
Do you need laws and taxes?
Absolutely.
The question is always in political
philosophy. How much do you need? Okay.
And it seems to me that we're headed to
a point where governments can be 42% of
GDP. I mean, we, we government
is taking over so much.
So many people in this country are
dependent on a government paycheck.
That's not the American way.
And I'll tell you something,
it means you're a bureaucratic,
it doesn't necessarily, you're,
some people are doing good things,
they're doing good things.
But for the most part, the, the, the,
uh, country grows when it starts,
when it produces things you and I need,
whether it's intellectual
ideas, physical products, uh,
and we export those things and we are,
we need to stay the leader of innovation,
innovation and ideas
is what it is so high.
But when you have Potomac being that rich,
because they basically would
lie on the u s government,
there's something fucking very wrong,
very creepy that it just keeps going on
and it never even gets mentioned because
it's very hard to stop.
To me,
it's one of the two great things about
politics that have always fascinated me.
That's one and two is cigarettes. The fact
that no one ever brings up cigarettes,
there's never a present president that
says we have to stop something that's
killing literally almost a half
a million, you know? Can I,
you know what I love about
that example you just used in,
in health and human resources.
There's a building in Washington where
you can go down one floor and there is a,
it's it's health and human health and
human resources or the health department.
The Department of Health and Department
of Health had to huge campaign to get
people to stop smoking and
it's a good noble program.
You go up three flights from
there or whatever it is,
but it's in the same building and you
have a essentially a the department of
agriculture. You know what the
Department of Agriculture does,
it pays farmers to produce tobacco because
it's called a subsidy. Interesting,
isn't it?
So you got one floor that's paying farmers
to grow tobacco because they have a
strong lobby.
And then if you go down three floors,
you've got the Department of Health,
which is trying to get
people to stop smoking.
You find me one business in the world
that behaves that way. But guess what?
It's the u s government baby and that's
how we work. And that's your taxes go.
Your taxes go to stopping
people from smoking with big,
big programs and they go to getting
farmers to grow more tobacco.
That's what it's called. So it's
called fucking madness. It is.
And that's why if you don't educate
yourself on how the government works and
what the history of
expansive government is,
you're gonna pay a price for it out of
your pocket book. And with your freedom.
It doesn't seem like as the economy
corrodes and they start trying to add more
and more government jobs,
people don't,
they don't want to resist this because
it does provide some sort of a tangible
boosting economy. They've created
2 million jobs, but you don't do,
they don't tell you that these 2 million
jobs are all sensor sends a census.
Census People, census takers, useless
jobs, exact things that we don't need.
Exactly. You know, it's
just pay attention.
When you hear a politician talk,
pay attention to what they're
really asking for it. It's a very,
very interesting thing
because it, the, the,
and all of us would be guilty of this
would the nature of human beings, if you,
in my opinion, you look at history is
to, is to try to control other people.
I try to do it. I try to do it with
people I love. I try to, I try.
I try to help them. I try to, I'm trying
to control them. I tell them how to eat.
It's my nature. I care about
people, so what am I going to do?
I'm going to try to get in there and I'm
gonna try to educate you according to
My, my paradigm. Well that's just my
nature. I'll never be any different.
The problem,
the founding fathers knew that was part
of human nature and that's why they
created a checks and balances. That's
why they created the, the nation.
This nation was founded on the idea that
you are self reliant, that, that, that,
that we you, if you're going to
create a alliances and stuff,
they should be voluntary alliances,
not government mandated alliances,
et cetera.
And we're headed to a point where people
are trying to solve problems and, and,
and that means I'm going to,
I'm going to pass a government mandate.
I'm going to make you do this. Do you
know how the tobacco lobby thing works?
Do you know how they pay the farmers?
The farmers get paid for their tobacco,
plus they get paid to grow it. Is that
how it goes? Hey to it? We'll look at yes.
Oh look. Just to make sure
that there's like everybody,
let me give you another example. Do you
think we need as much corn as we do?
You think we need all that corn syrup?
Do you think in fact,
why don't we grow sugar anymore?
Because the corn lobby lobby,
I think it's Archer Daniel
Midlands, uh, et cetera. Uh,
I have a very strong lobbying
groups. So they said, let's, let's,
we want to grow corn.
We have a lot of people that will be
out of work if you don't subsidize our
industry. You know how much
money we give. We give,
we give out pack a
farmer's money every year.
You ever worn anything without Paca
in it? Yeah. It's an animal that,
and what happened was
during the Korean War, uh,
we decided to make uniforms
out of our pack Alpaca.
And I'll pack a blend because they would
be warmer because Korea is very fucking
cold. But guess what? Those
farmers, they're still,
they're still getting
paid to grow alpacas to,
to hurt Alpacas and your,
you pay for it.
Now it might be 0.1% out of your paycheck,
but that's what goes
on with the government. That's
what government, that's what,
that's what farming subsidies are about.
That we pay people to produce butter.
We have a lot of food.
No, I said, yeah, I'm just saying like
every, if you have a farm, you get money.
Is that every, does it every crop, the,
I don't know all the details,
but for Reed Zachary,
I wrote a really good book about all
this stuff that everybody should be,
you should meet him. He's
smart. What's it called?
I believe it's called the history of
freedom. And I read some excerpts of it.
It was unbelievable.
There was no way to stop the lobby system
at this point though, is there, I mean,
is there no one's gonna no
one's gonna accept. There
absolutely is. They, in fact,
I would argue that there's
a huge movement, uh, to,
to bring government on both sides of
the aisle to bring government into a
manageable price. You know,
it's small to make it smaller.
I mean every time they're on pell Paul
Dogma, but nobody's, so we actually,
every time you hear a politician
now wants to get to be elected,
they all have to justify their spending.
And let me tell you something. We are in,
we are in dire,
I mean a lot of government programs
are being cut and the whole tea party
movement, which is a formidable
movement in some ways. Uh,
and Michelle Bachmann and
these guys, they, they, their
platform is basically like,
no matter what you say,
the government's too big.
Now I have some issues with those guys,
but I'm just saying that at the end of
the day they gained that much traction
because they said,
what the Hell's going on here?
Got Michele Bachmann is one of two things.
Either she's the bringer of the apocalypse
or she's a see someone hired by the
Democrats to completely discredit the
Republicans because she's at the helm
right now. She's at the, I did a little
wasted movement research on her. I was,
how about her gay husband? I don't
know anything about his fuck. Really.
Dave Foley turned me onto it. Oh, you got
to watch the guy talk. It's fantastic.
Yeah.
Married 35 years ago on the podcast.
He's one of those guys that curious people
being gang. Oh No. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Oh he's gay as fuck. You just hear him
talk and he can't hold the gay back. Yeah,
I have a huge problem with every like
called customer service somewhere and you
know you're talking to a black guy.
Yeah. That's how gay is. You know,
and I'm not saying that every
black guy talks like that,
but there are certain black guys at man
you call the guy up on the phone and I'm
not saying there's anything wrong with it,
but you know,
you're talking to a black guy.
This guy is one of those guys.
You hear him talking and go, that's
a gay guy. There's no doubt about it.
And he just talks about barbarians,
gay people being barbarians Healy.
And we need to tell them that this kind
of behavior is just not acceptable.
What asshole sucking cock
and prayer retreats and just
can't self self loathing.
He's got self-loathing and he's married.
I can't stand hypocrites.
I can't stand people like that.
She wants to get rid of all porn too,
which is hilarious because then the
rapes would go through the fucking roof.
It's one of the things that
they've realized in one thing.
They actually believe could help child
pornography could actually help child
molesters not have sex with children.
It's a terrible idea.
Scientifically,
scientifically though they're
proposing that this actually could be a
possibility because wood with,
um, it's, it's terrible idea,
but you know that you obviously could
never do it because those kids and those
videos are victims, but regular
pornography has been shown to curb rape.
Regular pornography in other
countries is accepted in Japan,
especially that pornography and even
violent things actually keep people from
acting out. A lot of psychological
studies about the fact that, you know,
movies like saw and stuff,
there's prop,
there are less maniacs out there actually
doing it because they can simulate,
they can see it being done and
get off on you bolt. Yeah. And I,
they think they believe this about
pornography as well. Sex pornography,
actually curbs rape totally makes
sense. It does. Yeah. I mean, look,
there's gotta be some reason for it
and that doesn't make sense. I mean,
it doesn't have to be some reason for it,
but I think the way the made
world moves outlaw pornography.
I want to make my own choices. I'm a
fucking adult. You fucking, what are you?
I mean the, the Nazis were very
good at, at totalitarianism,
at controlling the total person
too. That's, that's tyranny.
It's a form of tyranny.
When people start talking that way that
people want to keep your gay people like
fucking worry about your own kitchen,
asshole.
I never had a gay person come in and
fuck up my whole, the way they are.
They fucking up my, my fam, my
family unit with their presence.
Is that how weak my family unit bond is?
Are they tempting me within Cox
shot hop? Yeah, they are actually.
Sorry. Hi. Yeah, dude, I'm with Ya.
I'm with you on the whole ranch.
There's a bunch of people in this
country though that don't think that way.
That's one of the things about this
world is that, you know, there's,
there's people in this life that are at
various stages of awakening and I'm not
claiming to be any enlightened being,
but there's people that have the benefit
of having more free time or open minded
friends live in a better geographic
environment where people think a little
clear.
I'm very open minded.
There's a lot of people though in certain
spots of this country alone and forget
about the rest of the world,
but certain spots of the country,
but they're just in some fucked spot.
His spot,
they're was just filled with dummy. I
just think, I also think that there's,
there's a lot of social pressure
to stay, stay the course, you know,
I think it goes back to kind of
keeping like the breeding instinct.
I was thinking about this, I was trying
to write stay the course. So you say,
you mean like as far as like Christian
values and notice how it feels?
Shy Guy in a working class,
neighborhood of Boston walks in with
bangles and earrings and I shadow he gets
beaten up. Why? Why is that
though? Why I have a theory.
Why remember like a mud up David,
I'll use this thing when he was in
Jersey and he'd go to school and his mom
would pack pita bread and he'd get the
shit kicked out of pita bread. He's like,
hey ma, you know, give me white bread.
Cause I know Pete, it's good for me,
but it's not good for me when I get my
fucking teeth knocked him for being a
communist because I'm eating pita
bread. Right. It's hilarious. But why,
and I have a theory on it. Men, if
you look at like how men developed,
like men are really good in groups. They
delineated authority very quickly. They,
they uh, they work well. They're
very organized. They like hierarchy.
They don't talk a lot. If they
have a job to do, they get it done.
Think about like, you know when they're
like, well, like when you're hunting,
it goes back to hunting. When you got
to hunt a deer, you gotta, you gotta,
you gotta you're using hand signals,
you're not talking to,
he'll scare the deer away. So
you, you, you get into this
whole, this whole sort of,
you know, uh, a very
organized, you become one unit.
I machine women don't bond that way.
They tend to talk and, and, and they,
they verbally, men
actually don't. Men Bond.
If you take boys and you take a ball
and throw it in the middle of a bunch of
boys don't know each other,
they'll be come friends around that ball.
Cause they start playing a game and they
break up into teams and they compete
with, they have to rely on each other and
they get very good and they do it right
away.
It's how you get boys to be friends.
Girls don't that girls
don't make friends that way.
Girls have to make friends over a
period of time through experience.
You have to talk shit about some other
girl. That's why we, that's why. Yeah.
That's why when you, that's exactly
right. That's why when you adopt a child,
if she's a girl and she's a little
older and you put her in a new scroll,
she has a much harder time making
friends and the boy does when he's just,
you know around when you call, you
can just put it, yeah. When you,
when he's around fucking balls.
Boys make friends with boys quicker than
probably girls can make friends with
girls. I wouldn't think that though
because girls are friendlier. No,
but boys try to beat your ass when you
move into town. But, but, but the point,
but I think the reason that the reason
that somebody gets beaten up when they
show up with all this decoration is
because you can't go hunting with somebody
with jewelry on.
It makes too much fucking noise.
And he's walking around with his bangles.
I clang,
clang and I fucking deer are gone.
If you're shiny and you got glitter on,
why don't guys wear glitter
and Shiny Shit? Why not? Well,
what if he's shirt and a bow tie and
skinny jeans? I want to beat him. I,
and that's pretty sleek for the woods.
I think that might also be this,
that and that. It might also be
you're, you're trying to get the girls,
you're not working with us.
You're fucking showing off your
tits and ass and you're not,
you didn't get permission
from US mother fucker.
So like you can't walk in like the king
peacock because then guys going to be
like, that guy's a fucking peacock.
And I guess he thinks he said, yeah,
he thinks he's a tough guy cause
he's showing me his muscles,
which is an affront to me.
You're, you're, you're,
you're preening what if he's really
skinny and he's got no muscles. It's like,
you know, some guys are, he's fine. Like
if a guy like you were as a tank top,
of course it's imposing. Thank you. But
uh, you know, some guys wear tank tops,
like a real skinny guy, you know, like
Chris Rock was a tank top, you know,
it's not school. I don't think that's
the guy that gets beaten up at tomorrow.
Then the guy that wears a tank top is,
and he's all rocked out and he walks in.
There are a lot,
there are a lot of guys like do that with
man when he's got a couple of drinks.
I'm sure man, I'd be like, Hey, this guy,
you know what, I'm gonna start with that.
Who would just hold onto you for 15
seconds until you're out of breath.
That's all it would take for.
Especially for some juice head. Oh,
you just gotta hang on,
it's a ride and you've got a 15 second
ride and at the end of that ride
and then he can't push. Funny
Man. I remember my buddy
Bob Williams, that awesome.
That is strong man who's a fucking
maniac and he's so fucking strong.
He so weird. Strong. And he'd
always go up to the guys and, and,
and colts and he'd be like, what's up
Beatles? How you doing? God be like,
excuse me. Yeah. Ah, needles,
needles, calling needles, God.
And he just wanted a little,
just a little like, you know,
let me just squeeze you until
he was a wrestler, right.
Since he was seven with a chimpanzee.
I call him the human chimp. He, uh,
had one of the best lines ever.
Tell the story about the
guy who was fucking with him
while he was surfing. Yeah,
he's the best. He's on it. He's on a
surfboard and his buddies with him and,
and he's fucking dudes
come up these local,
these Amalga locals would like
tattoos on the neck, rough guys.
And they look at Bob and they go, hey
bro, get the fuck off our wave right now.
And Bob Goes, why? He does this
thing where he have to know him.
He's got to kind of an eye loose.
She's like, Eh. And,
and he looks like JFK jr has got like
the really thick hair and his eyes like a
real good looking guy. And they go
get the fuck off, get the fuck off.
Our wave will kick your fucking
ass. And so Bob, you gotta know,
he's like really loose. He
never gets afraid of it. And
he goes like this. He goes,
Eh, Eh, how long can you hold your
breath? And the guy goes, what?
He goes,
how long can you hold your breath?
Because I can hold my breath for over
four minutes so I could jump off this
board. I grab you by the hair,
I bring you to the bottom.
We take a little nap and you just
fucking die. And then I come for you.
And they were like, oh, fuck this battle.
And he's got these huge hands
and when he takes his shirt off,
you can't really do anything about
that either. If they couldn't help him,
oh dude, they would have to pull
him off. They would be underwater.
There was his eyes.
Now you look into his eyes,
it's like they had a great white
siting out in Malibu and he's like,
I'm going surfing and go, dude, there they
have the great white was is out there.
They had a ceiling. It's mouth.
He's like, shut the fuck up.
I punch a great white and his fucking
face. He, he literally see, he's like,
they won't eat me. I go, what do you
mean the one of, they smell it on me.
They're not going to a
fuck. Says, well that's,
that's a good way to lose your life.
I know he's a fucking maniac.
Wasn't the spawn a great white and
Malibu's ever recently? Oh yeah,
that there was a great way to 200 feet
off the shore with a seal in its mouth.
Holy Shit. It was like Holy Shit. And the,
and the fucking shark expert was like,
ah, hey guys, they've always been out
there. They're always swimming under you.
That's their breeding ground.
They eat seal there.
They're there all the fucking time.
So all you guys think there
are no sharks in that water.
There are great whites swimming
under you all the time,
but you're just not food to them.
They'd rather read a seal. Oh,
you're so lucky you're
talking David Blaine.
David Blaine came to my house
and he and I said, he want,
he wanted to cross the ocean in a bottle.
Oh Shit. I hope. Fuck David. Sorry if I,
I don't think he'd do it anyway. He
didn't this merge. You want to do this?
He's standing on literally ever. Literally
he wanted to do that. He wanted to go.
So he's into these and so he
goes, um, but, but, but I, I said,
aren't you afraid a shark too? They
were talking about how whales, Orcas,
if you're in a glass boats on myself,
crash the wit and they don't know
why wo and a guy died that way. So,
so he was like, yeah, that's a problem.
And I said, aren't you afraid of sharks?
I great whites. And he goes,
Oh, you didn't see my video?
I go, no. He goes, Oh dude,
I'm not afraid in them at all.
So what on his iPhone he's got,
he's in a tough fuck.
I don't know if I can say this though,
because it might say it. Fuck
them. Fuck David Blaine. Nice.
My wouldn't hold on it. No, cause I don't
want to screw up as special, but listen,
you don't want to screw up this youtube
Ustream show was 2000 people. Well, yeah,
yeah.
You fuckers anywhere else in 659 I gotta
I gotta get permission from anyway,
the point is he, he's, he's swimming
with great whites. Uh, and, uh,
all I can say,
I don't want to ruin anything,
but he's basically without
any protection at all,
slowing his heart rate down and just in
the middle of the ocean with a weight
belt on flow, no oxygen, no nothing
holding his breath while huge,
great whites go by him and all
he can see his shadows. What?
Yeah, that's David Blaine. He's not,
it's not magical though. No, it's not,
not magical. He's, he's, yeah, he's, he's,
I think he's very fascinating
in that he's made this living,
doing these endurance things and he's,
you know why he's always been David.
His mother was, um, was,
uh, Jewish and, and uh,
and so he was always obsessed with the
Holocaust, but also his mother died very,
very painfully and slowly of
cancer. And I, when I met him,
she was going through this terrible
time and it was very hard for him.
And he always, he became
obsessed with suffering and with,
with how to suffer with dignity,
how to overcome, in my opinion.
I'm speaking for him,
but we've talked a little bit about it,
but David's read so much about the
Holocaust and so much about, you know,
a man's search for meaning by Viktor
Frankl and those kinds of guys. He,
he's obsessed with the notion of how
one deals with all the suffering in the
world. He's got a huge heart
that's so is his fascination,
has led him into dealing with adverse
situations like really bizarre situation
standing in that ice cube,
remembering names, you know,
he broke the world record for
holding his breath. That's true.
He did a Ted lecture on
it. He goes, you know,
he's trying to figure out a way to do the
trick. We held his breath and he goes,
the craziest thing is if I actually
did it and he fucking did it,
it's held his breath on Oprah for
17 minutes, but 17 fucking minutes.
He's got a record. 17 minutes, 17 minutes.
He really didn't heard of that before.
That was about [inaudible] seven he can
slow the heart rate down. He's amazing.
Holy. That is no joke. I can't believe you
don't know him. He's a very special guy.
I always thought that he edited
his magic shit like Angel,
let me tell you something. He, he's, he's
so far from Chris Angel. It's crazy. Yeah.
Chris Angels,
angels and some big silly face.
David David's been offered more money
than you can fucking imagined to do shit
and he just won't do it. When he did
that thing for target, he, he didn't,
he wasn't,
he was like making no money for his
magic tricks cause you wouldn't anybody
sponsor him. And, and so when he did that
thing for target, he said, I'll do this,
but you guys have to, I'll do this
magic. Do you want us to sponsor me?
But for getting money from me, you
guys have to, I want you to do,
you got to let really poor children have
a total shopping spree and you're in
all your stores. So he's like a
really, he's really somebody who cares.
I've got a lot.
And it gets,
why do so many people hate him because
they don't know him because he's a,
he's a stud.
And because the same reason people just
don't think people hate David Blaine.
I think people hate me for Saint Joe.
No, I hate Chris Angel. Definitely.
Hey Chris Angel as well.
Um,
because because they probably that
people don't like to be fooled people,
no food.
There's no fooling them though because
he's just doing these endurance stunts.
He's a weird guy in that he's don't
known as David Blaine the magician,
but everything he does is just
like this weird physical feat.
He's like a Houdini type character.
When I was,
when I knew him when he was 17 he was
obsessed with it and he just thought
[inaudible] he's always
been obsessed with it.
But it's kind of a shame that
he's a magician because you know,
they are like world events when he does
something nutty. I mean it really is.
Like it or not, they are
world events, you know,
like what did he do in London where
we lived on a platform or some shit.
What the fuck did you do in
a box spinning in a bridge.
But he's always been obsessed with
this notion that how can I deal with,
if you put me shave my head
and throw me in a corner,
it was a bowl of grill in a concentration
camp. How can I suffer with dignity?
How would I be the best suffer? How would
I deal with that? And what did he do to
bathroom when he was up in that box?
Well, first of all, he was, he was
drinking and eating very little, but I'm,
I think he went, he had a thing that he
would go to the bathroom and I guess,
I don't know. I got a bucket. Yeah, you
have to do. And everybody's asleep. Yeah.
I guess you're only out a PK.
So hobbit,
although it was a clear plastic
box and he was just sitting there.
There should be some youtube video of
him pooping. Then if I remember, I,
I think they did.
They put it off.
I think they put like a towel around it
at when he had to go to the bathroom.
Right, right. If I remember,
that's how they did it.
How long was he in that box
for? I Dunno. Like 18 days.
Have you ever been to the Magic
Castle? Never. I have one.
I've got a friend when he
liked did Jujitsu with two
is a magician. Really? Yeah.
Yeah. He's always inviting me. But you
got to wear a jacket. You do. I know.
I want to go
get out of here.
What your stupid fucking outfit I have
to wear. That's he seems so dorky.
Why can't I just wear a nice shirt?
I have to wear a jacket.
I liked it. I liked the way
you wear it for the UFC. You.
I was just kind of put on a black shirt.
Friction plays me to wear their shirts
or were a black affliction shirt every
time, but then it flicks and right
now this one. Yeah. This is Jujitsu,
my friend grace. Grace. This
is the Godfather. I don't know.
Yeah, probably. You need some Jujitsu in
your life, doesn't he? No. I really do.
As a man is screaming out for Jujitsu.
This price,
you got to do a little rolling you, but
you got to actually kind of built for it.
You've got some shoulders aren't, it?
Doesn't want to do it. It's not that guy.
You're that guy though, aren't you? Yes,
I miss Roslyn. Why don't you go back in?
I'm going, you got a bad
concussion, right? Tell that story.
That's a pretty crazy story. I just had
this war with his kid, Pascal and booboo.
Manzini was watching me and
I wasn't going to give up.
And we wrestled at a street
sports and not the magnet school,
which is a great school and
he's a great guy. And uh,
and we rolled and rolled and rolled.
I was probably the 40 minutes and I just,
nobody won. It was like coat to withdraw
the next day. I felt like my hands,
like they would,
they,
I felt like I was holding a hot snow
ball in my hands and I couldn't see very
well. It was all things where I just, I
just was, my perception was all messed up.
And uh, I went to the doctor
and they did it like a cat scan.
So having the guy said you just got
commutes, got a concussion. But for,
for about six months after that I would
have these weird sensations in my hands
because I neurologically did
something cause I'd hit my head,
I was in such a f it was such a fight,
you know,
you don't want to lose and you
go a little too crazy and uh,
concussions are scary things, man. People
take that shit real lightly. Um, you know,
I have friends, like I've got a friend
who got hit in the head by a golf ball.
He said he was not the same person for six
months. No, I've been, I got in college,
I got kicked by four guys
on the ground and uh,
and I remember just being truly
cloudy for five days. I just,
it was just so cloudy. I just got my
head kicked and I was in the library.
May Have you ever had that done to you?
Man?
It's really weird cause it's
exactly what you must have,
what your sock feels like in a dryer. I
was just getting, I couldn't do anything.
You know about Bill Roman.
I'll ski.
The football player had
over 20 concussions and he
created a bunch of brain
supplements he created.
He's got this stuff called
neuro one I've taken it before.
It's pretty fucking strong shit.
It's really good like for concentration
and showing that, you know, it's just,
it's basically caffeine and a bunch
of different brains. Stimulants.
But I mean this guy has a,
I'm going to ask you,
it was a monster man when he's tried very
hard to try to kind of balance out all
the impacts that he's had. He really
tough to have that kind of trauma,
concussions because it creates,
it creates pugilistic dementia mean those
guys all their brain shrink and yeah,
that's something,
I mean it's amazing that just realizing
this over the last few decades too,
you know,
I mean everybody knew that football
players got beat up and nobody ever like
Kinda put ball is so beyond rough three
rate as a hundred percent it's not 95
it's 100% you play with pain in the NFL.
That's why people talk about
this guy is really tough. This,
they're great athletes. Play football, go
run out and run it. Run a fucking uh, uh,
football back in the NFL. Good luck.
Yeah, those are the super athletes, man.
Those are the elite of the elite weeks.
What's really crazy is that
I've read that something,
some ridiculous number like
after two years of retirement,
80% of NFL players filed for bankruptcy
and 60% of NBA talking about that last
time, how fucking five years
of leaving the NBA and the NFL,
60% of football players file file for
bankruptcy because nobody's there to tell
him, hey dude, you know, football is
different. Don't spend your money.
Nobody's ever told them that and the fact
that they had been compromised by all
these impacts,
it's got to make them more impulsive.
Effector judgment affect how they
behave already dealing with a high
testosterone, fun, love and Kinda rough
forward tilted group. And these guys,
these guys are the wolves.
They're the Alpha dogs.
They come in and everybody
else is a fucking hen.
What those guys did you ever see like
a team of real football players come in
here like savages?
It's like being in night when I was
in Afghanistan and I just got caught.
But guys who walked by me with beards
and long hair and he's, I was like, Oh,
who are those guys? Oh they're
really muscular guys. The the guys,
the guys who are not saying anything
with no badges. That's the dark side.
That's who that is. Oh. I was like,
oh, those are the real elites.
That's why I smell gun metal and
death on him. And I was like,
oh no,
just the delta guys that was real
elite and like seal team six,
you know whoever they were and they
weren't talking to me. Yeah. What a,
what a strange way to go and live your
life to commit to being one of the most
disciplined, hardened,
well-trained, fighting,
killing machines in the world.
My buddy hangs with those
guys in Afghanistan and he
works with them and he said,
I said, what delineates had delta force
guy from like a regular, you know,
like a seal team or regular guy. And
he said they're exact. And I was like,
what do you mean? He goes, they're just
exact. They're uh, they're amazing shots.
They're good at everything, but they're
just really good at everything. Like,
exactly.
Well rounded.
Like there's a place for everybody
in this world and there's a,
there's a place for someone to be a guy
who makes pottery and is a place for
Picasso and there's a place for
fucking killers, man. I mean,
as long as we're allowing
war as war seems to be legal,
the president seemed to, I
believe, celebrate that we
had just murdered a bad guy.
I mean, that's what the whole Osama
bin Ladin thing is. What they came in,
the guy shot him above the eye and
then took a picture and sent a fee.
If send it back to their computer to
facial recognition program. Ready?
Your girls coming at me in the leg and
get out of the way like that in head in
case you got to suicide.
Ah Ha.
Let me take out my Polaroid chicken
and I'm going to just facts.
Let me scan this and send
it back to the White House.
He ain't got the guy's face.
Let's take this picture.
Let's run it through the
facial recognition there.
Yeah, it's an it's amps.
Do a hundred percent believe
this story though. Yes.
I do know why there were 17 people
involved. I have to pay 70. Uh, yeah,
70 dog.
So good luck trying to cover that up.
And then the one time watching Greg About
Jessica Lynch where they've tried to
pretend there was a gun shootout and
she was actually just in the hospital.
Go make your PP,
Bro.
We're going to talk about
Pat Tillman to conspiracies.
Brian's not buying them. Brian is my, uh,
most Fox News like friend.
Did you see the new footage of I think
with the World Trade Center, uh, footage.
Oh yeah,
I did see from the one reporter's
perspective that show it's a completely
different,
I mean that shit looked like eight,
which is sitting there fucking melting
like the building that building or seven
noises. It was amazing.
Totally, totally. It did. Look,
I've always said that that
tower seven looks ridiculous.
It looks like a controlled demolition,
but the fuck do I know.
I'm not an engineer.
It might've looked like
controlled demolition just
because of the very bizarre
way in which it was injured that it
was injured on the bottom floors.
And that's what gave him first and
everything pancaked down. Very possible.
The fuck do I know, but it does
look like a controlled demolition.
But that video is,
what I thought was most fascinating was
all the buildings are the cars outside
that had been blown up and on fire. Like
I didn't realize that that had happened.
I kind of like thought that of
course everything fell and collapsed,
but I thought there was probably like
just this massive pile of debris.
I didn't realize that all these cars were
like had been lit on fire and fuel and
everything just kind of fell down into
the street. I wouldn't want to, yeah,
that's what the airplane,
Hey, it just fucking fire.
And Brian comes back.
He's got a crazy fucking story of
his buddy that was a actual, um,
uh, uh, Wall Street.
He was a stockbroker and he was there
while it all happened and he heard sounds
that sound like car
accidents, just Bam, Bam.
And then he realized, tell the
story about your friend who, uh,
had heard those sounds. He was at
September 11th, heard those sounds,
that sounded like car accidents
and then realize what they were.
That's what there was this,
in fact,
there's a documentary that captured
it by the way. But yeah, he, he uh,
he just started hearing like these
goosh she was like two cars ramming and
Jewish. So there's 40 miles an hour
or 50 miles an hour. And uh, it was,
it turned out it was the bodies
hitting, uh, hitting the pavement,
hitting the ground. How many people do
you think jumped? They don't really, I,
they probably have that figure,
but a lot because what happened was it
got so hot and rather than burns you,
you jumped in and some people held hands.
Some people form groups and saw that.
I saw that. Holy Shit. What a way to go
home. The way to go, man, it's a quick,
it's a, yeah. I don't know your phone
time. God damn the has to be horrifying.
Yeah. I'm afraid of heights.
So, uh, I, I perish.
And it's saw saying you're afraid of
heights that is beyond the afraid of
heights. Well, you know, that's a
good story. It's like a, you know,
Jay Burke knows Jimmy Burke knows
a certain, somebody who's who's,
who was terrified of flying,
she was seeing a therapist for it and
she finally worked up the courage to get
on a plane and fly.
And uh,
the plane broken half in the middle of the
air, it broken half on takeoff. So she,
she fell backwards in a,
in a half a plane and you
probably alive for a little while.
When you're playing brain breaks in
half, that's not fun. That's a, that's,
that's a, that's a you. The secret is
real. And she manifested done. Man.
I know. Or maybe she was a psychic
and she predicted her own demise.
She knew her timeline was tryna
raises a question, what's, what,
what's the way you'd want to die?
Uh,
I'd want to die with a mask on in an orgy.
I'm glad you brought that up because a,
it's reminds me of a story.
I experienced a story that Brian was
telling me yesterday that it was so good.
I said, stop talking, stop talking, and
told me this tomorrow. Well, you know,
low can't tell the names involved.
I can't tell the names.
There was a celebrity of them all,
but it's a very significant celebrity.
When we were growing up, this
celebrity was a big star. Yes. And,
and uh, I'll tell you it to say whether
or not they were a part of no, we cannot,
we cannot say anything else. Telly
Savalas no, no, no. But, um, but, uh,
the handsome young men,
can you say a music star?
A movie still not allowed to say.
And anybody who was a celebrity,
he was a celebrity, let's
put it that way. And, and um,
and the reason I don't only say things
because, you know, it was a private thing.
I mean, I admire the guy. Actually,
I half are doing what he did,
but I'm used to tell us what happened.
Well, you know, in life, I was just many,
many moons ago, many moons
ago, many, many moons ago, uh,
at least I think six years ago or
something. And I was single. Um, and I,
I, uh, there are things certain guys
want to do, you know, you want to like,
I always say this, you go,
you want to stop a crime?
Do you want to kill somebody with a sword?
You want to fucking, you know, uh, uh,
and then you want to bang six girls
at the same time. I mean, that's,
that's one of my goals. Six. Well,
I'm driving a penis. Do you have,
and I do. Well, and I'll show
you, I'll show you after the
story. Uh, but I, I'm, uh,
I'm driving to Venice.
I get a call from a girl I used to bang,
who was a rig.
Wonderful. I mean a
real Vegas pro. So, uh,
she gives me a call and she goes,
what are you doing? And I go,
I driving to Venice. She goes, she
goes, get your ass up to this hotel.
And it was, it was, let's
just call it the shirt.
And she was getting your ass to
the Sheraton right now we got,
we got six girls and only two Cox.
We need you now.
So I'm like, ah. I'm like,
Nah, I can't, I fucking,
I got an audition for Sydney Pollack
the next day, which I did. Right.
And I'm like, I need some Paul's brother.
Yes it is. Yes. The painter and I go,
I can't, I gotta go. I gotta go to fucking
the, I can't do it. That's probably, yeah,
I can't, you know what I'm
going on my way to now. All you,
the only thing you can do in that
situation is just faint. Otherwise,
just a faint,
faint Bica or,
or die there or pull over and sleep and
wake up in the morning because any other
movement is going to bring
you toward six hot girls.
Cause I knew the kind of grocery
hot with, um, now I'm going,
you mean there's a fucking,
there's fucking en suite and the Sharon,
will you tell the story before
you even go any further?
You decided to tell this story recently
at the UCB I told the story at the UCB
podcast and it was interesting because
they're all a very nice group and very
funny and talented group of people,
but they are, um, they're not,
they probably not live the kind of
sexual deviancy that I have gone through,
you know? And so I just feel that they
just seem like wholesome good people,
you know, that don't have just this
deep dark matter living inside there.
And so I got up and told this story
that I'm about to tell you guys about
essentially my experience
in a fucking orgy. Uh,
and then what made you want
to tell this? I just, I,
I fucking want to tell the
truth about who I really am.
I just felt like I just felt
like going up and going,
and he's a really cute story. Stories
you guys. Uh, now let me tell you what,
I'll fucking deviant.
I really am. You know,
when you didn't think there were cute
stories. I mean, I didn't really,
I didn't listen that hard, but, but I
know that people involved, they're funny.
I mean in law, but cycling Moisha this,
the standard Kong Moishe's funniest shit.
He's funny. He's got a great
sense of humor and the other guys,
I haven't seen a lot of their work,
but it used to be,
puts out some pretty bad ass
comics. I mean, it's funny,
funny fucking people like Amy Poehler
came out of there and you know,
great people.
And so they're telling their stories and
for whatever reason you decided to take
it down per lane. That's all. Tell
a story that you never even told me.
I've never told anybody because you
know, I mean, it's just, it's just like,
I was like,
I want to tell something that's a little
outrageous because I don't want any
secrets in my fucking life.
I just want to,
I just want to be fucking out
there and I don't give a fuck.
I don't care what really
care what other people think.
I care what my friends think.
You know,
and my friends all know exactly who the
fuck I am. All my friends know who I was.
So much freedom in that. But there's
always freedom and that I can't,
I'm not good at keeping lot of
facade up. So I tell this story. So,
so I'm driving and I go,
I hang on my first impulse,
I can't do what I can do it now. I had
listened, there was this thing where I'm,
you might've told me Joel,
but we were talking about a woman who
was dying of cancer. And they said,
if you could do it all over again,
what would you do? And she said, I,
I wouldn't do anything because
it made sense. And I am,
I was thinking about that when I got this
phone call. I was thinking, you know,
I want to, I want to do, you know,
you gotta leave your life sometimes
and you've got to have experiences and
you've got to fucking do something
that kind of shocked and astonished as
yourself.
And by the way,
you don't know a guy out
there who wouldn't want to
fuck six girls at the same
time. So I hear that. But I'm driving and
I, my first time, Nah, I gotta go get it.
I've got to study my audition.
I got an audition tomorrow,
but now I'm thinking only fuck
these girls. You know what I'll do?
I'm going to drive. If I see a
seven 11 I'll stop and get condoms.
It doesn't mean I'm going there.
I'm not trying to grab my,
but I'm going to stop and maybe if I
got another call, no good. Some other,
oh look,
a seven 11 or I'm going to pull off,
but I'm definitely not going in this
chair it and there's no way I blah blah.
And I go, Oh, you guys don't have any
condoms. Buy Condoms. Phone rings again.
Where the fuck are you?
So while this is going on,
you're basically like a
junkie that someone's saying,
come on, let's do some blow.
I'm not basically like a junkie. I am
a junkie. All right. There's no it is.
But that feeling when you're about to
do something really deviant is junky.
Junky my heart.
My Heart's beating fast and I'm getting,
and I can get it out of my mind.
I keep going back to it.
I keep trying to put it out of
my mind and I'm losing. And Matt,
I'm losing the battle.
I'm getting pulled under.
They're adding more and more weight and
I'm trying to keep up. I got my, I'm like,
okay, I can't go under water. I
keep doing this. I'm treading water,
but they're just adding weights
to my legs with the imagery.
I'm thinking about these girls.
Long story short, I go, fuck it.
I find myself at the Sheraton.
I go up to the suite,
I get met at the door by my girl.
She's wearing a mask.
She gives me a porcelain
doll mask to put on.
So I go,
oh.
And then she gives me a strip of
paper with the rules of the game,
which is that this is a
birthday girl and my, um,
and I am fucking, uh, the only rule is
I can't hit or spit. I'm like, okay.
I wasn't planning on hitting and spitting
these girls. I'm going to fuck them.
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Is this stuff written down?
[inaudible] printed is written,
typed. Very Neat Strip of paper. Wow.
So this is well organized. So
everyone has a sheet. I walk in,
I walk in and I go and I see fucking
four of the hottest girls I've ever seen.
One girl was getting banged on the bed
by some muscular dude and then there's a
dude who's kind of just standing off to
the side not doing anything with like a
shaved jazz. And I'm like, I
don't like that guy. He's weird.
He's getting fucking looks all bloated.
He's just like been lifting a lot of
ways and never did a sport in his life.
I'm like, whatever. Shaved
chests, orange is orange, orange,
the shape and some weird mask. I was
like, all right. Then I look at myself,
everyone's naked dude. Yeah.
And guess what? She goes,
you got to take her clothes off right
now. You'd have to get no, no clothes.
So she starts peeling my pants off. She
gets on her knees and starts to work me.
And as I'm getting work by my,
my old girlfriend,
I got this porcelain doll mascot.
I look in the mirror and I look at
my fucking dumb ass and I go, ah,
there's the first off. Literally not
on my Dick is getting sucked. I go,
that's weird. My fucking dog
Maskus is what is my legs?
I've got to start tanning.
That's gross. I'm like, I'm fucking
gross. And it's one girl goes,
yeah, you, you at the white skin
and that doll masking a hard on.
That's not creepy. I'm like,
oh, Yay, whatever. So this,
this really hot girl who turns out to be
the birthday girl who happens to be the
celebrities wife,
she gets down on her knees and I get
pushed over to her and now I'm getting
worked by her. But the thing is,
she's really fucking good at it.
And I go, um, I'm going to
go, I'm not a porn star.
I when a girl is hot as mommy with a
mask on and I'm totally anonymous with a
mask on my face,
I'm fucking going to come.
And plus I got to come cause I got an
audition tomorrow, so I want it now.
So I'm like, oh. And I go, I'm
going to fuck you, keep doing it.
I'm going to come and the guy
and I hear you're to come.
And I look over and it's a guy, I'm
like, I think I recognize that guy.
I know him from somewhere,
but whatever.
He goes whole lot shoe and a video camera
comes out and it's right on the girl.
And I'm like, Oh really? All right. I
guess this was like the Duke Porn. Woo.
My knees lock up and who,
which by the way,
I never locked their mouth
or face where in her mouth.
My friends and the
husband is filming this.
He films that and uh,
yeah.
And then I hope I don't ever have to do
a Disney show cause I'm fucking fucked.
This is all fiction is, is all fiction.
But this is, this is part of the,
this is part of my fictional story
that I'm doing on stage one man show.
Yes. Okay. Yeah. So now, now,
um, now I, uh, by the way,
I'm speaking,
this actually happened to a friend
and I'm speaking and telling you,
I'm telling the story. How can
we got enough disclaimers? Yeah,
just tell her like three of them that has
happened to my friend and, and so, uh,
so now I go, oh shit.
I just lost it. Good.
I can get the fuck out of here.
Cause this is a freak show and I
don't belong here. And I, you know,
I got an orange guy in the corner with,
I have a hard on and another dude banging
on a grill on a bed. And I got, I got,
I mean, I'm like, I get it the
fuck Outta here, but you know what?
I had an experience. I'm going to go
and I can go make my Sydney Pollack, uh,
audition. So I'm putting on my
pants and I'm about to leave.
I'm sneaking out and all of a sudden this
10 with a mass comes up and she goes,
you're not going to fuck me.
And I go, uh, oh.
I mean, I, I was going to go, I
have a d and I would almost say it,
I'll just buy it. Even know I was
mad at her. I'm like, she goes,
you're not gonna find me. And she
turns around and I go, I mean,
I don't want to be rude.
Maybe I should fuck you.
So next thing I know my pants are coming
off and you know, that's it now. Now,
now I'm in the belly of the beast now
and I'm just seeing fucking read and I'm
just going crazy. I login and they're
like, hey, this guy's out rate.
I was appalling. I was appalling. My
energy level noises, I gave it up. I,
at this point, I'm like, I'm fucking gone.
Now know on the other people
grunting or is everyone kind of road?
They were kind of done
second, I'm going in for,
and everybody else quit. They kind
of quit. And then that athletic,
lucky not to be a dick, but my, my dig
was the mover then weren't doing so well.
So I'm just fucking going crazy. I'm
like, this is, look at this shit. I,
we're really Argo. And, Oh
yeah, I'll switch. Oh, why not?
Hey, free country, whatever.
Fuck you America.
And I'm going nuts.
And now I fucking get to a
point where, um, uh, uh, I'm,
I'm now the girl who's the burden girl
goes, I want some of this. And she says,
don't use him up to the girl that
I'm going crazy on. She pushes, she,
she pushes me down on the bed.
She gets on top of me.
So as I'm being taken care
of by this beautiful girl,
now I'm being worked on my back and
trying my hardest not to lose it.
Um, cause she's so
beautiful. And so, uh, uh,
all of a sudden at this point,
the celebrity who now I now recognize
cause he's drunk and the mask is crooked
on his face. So it's like, I'm
like, bye. See your face. All right.
Well they are and they don't. And he
goes, I want to get home and get it.
Let me get, let me, let
me get you, you know,
he wants a sandwich or he wants to
go in, in south. So he wants to,
why she's on top of you. He wants
us to get in around. Yes. Oh,
she turns to him cause she calls
the whole thing's a disaster,
right. So she looks back and she goes, she
says to him, she goes, um, something like,
you know, like she does this, like the
silent kind of like language. Like, no,
I don't want to do that right now too.
He's like,
come on [inaudible] and
there's a debate going on.
So finally she hits back to me and
we, by the way, we're connected.
We're connected. We're making love
at this point. Okay. Yeah. Yours,
your Dick's in her vagina and his
Dick in her butt hole. He tries,
but he can't get it.
And many times it is Dick touch yours.
Never if you did.
And if it did,
it doesn't matter because I wouldn't
have felt that anyway. I don't care.
I'm not squeamish there. I said
it really well. I don't know. I'm,
I'm doing all this girl, this girl. Well,
okay, so he's got a fungus on his balls.
I'll do that. I don't know. I wasn't even
thinking, dude. I was just like, this is,
this is an experience I'm already
done. I'm already fucked. So,
so he can't get in. And, and she,
and he goes, ah. He goes, oh,
what the fuck are kicking in? And
she turns around and goes, what the,
don't fucking play me.
I told you I didn't want to do it.
And they started having a fight about
not being able to get an harass as I'm
having sex with her and they're having
a fight. And I'm thinking to myself,
I look back and like,
that's,
this is the beginning of the
end and this relationship,
this is a weird thing to have a fight
about it. There's another issue like that,
you know, you're fucking
Nigga, that's her, whatever.
I get that, but are swingers.
So,
so he can't get in.
They have this fight and then he kind of
storms off and she kind of goes back to
me and we do our thing. And so, uh,
so now I can't believe this is like
the most popular podcasts. Now.
There goes my reputation
by the way. And so now, uh,
it comes time for me to, she wants
me to finish off in a porn fashion,
which would be again in her
mouth. And so I go, okay,
and so now we're going to do
the whole money shot thing.
And I just, it's been a long time and I
just lose it, you know, right away again.
And as I'm, you know, coming, uh, I,
I see Mr Celebi come running around with
the camera and he calls me and he goes,
oh, what the fuck? Hey, why'd
you let him call him so fast?
I wanted to film it.
And she goes,
what am I supposed to stick my dick in
his fucking up the stick my finger in his
dick. Don't be an asshole. I
don't have any control of it.
And they now they get an argument about
that. And as their argument, I'm like,
I go, all right, thank you so
much. I throw all my fucking man.
I run the fuck out of there. And
by the way, then they got divorced.
Have you ever seen that guy since
then? Oh No. That would came to mind.
My lucky guess. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
I gotta I gotta I gotta save some
anyway. I wasn't there. By the way.
That story that doesn't belong to me.
That's a, that's a friend of mine story.
But I was new stream.
His apparently died be noticed what
happened. Is it us? No, it's not us.
It's the yesterday cause
cause my old ninth,
the people in the tribe is it
just Ustream crashed. Yeah.
Sorry. Well we're still broadcasting. Yes.
You have to download it from my team
and sung the end part. The best part.
So, um, you've never had a
situation like this ever again.
This was one of those
stories that you hear about.
Like that's like a Hollywood story I've
had. I've had those experiences. How many?
More than one?
Yeah.
How many times have you had been in the
same room with another guy? With a girl?
How many times?
I mean,
I mean I don't want to get too detailed,
but when I was single in La and
I'm on and, and you know, with,
with a house and no worries.
And that was a young guy.
Why I did that kind of stuff all the
time. I mean, I didn't have, I didn't,
I wasn't a swinger. I didn't go to orgies.
I didn't organize anything. But I've,
I was pretty good at getting,
I think my friends would tell I was
pretty good at getting a group of great
openminded girls together and hogging off.
Funny thing to talk about though,
isn't it?
It's a funny thing to talk about
because when you, when you start saying,
you know,
banged all these girls,
I bang this girl by now you
open yourself up to people
getting angry. I don't care. I know
you don't. I know you don't. I don't,
I don't because, because I do anything
wrong. I didn't do anything wrong and,
and I, and I would do it again and
I had a blast. I have fucking blast.
And it's true. And it turned
me on. Is that turned me on.
You want to turn me on you,
you know,
you throw a bunch of like six really cool
girls in a room and they're all like,
we want to fuck you. Uh, I, that turns me
on. Yeah, it turns me off. Gets me going.
Sorry. But no, it's a cry. But
yeah, I'm down. Isn't it funny? Yeah
though, that you, you think about
this like the way people describe it,
like this is a fucked
up thing to talk about.
Yeah. But that's what's interesting.
Yeah. It's taboo because I,
when I was telling the story of UCB,
it was actually kind of an experiment.
I was like,
I want to see what happens to this
audience when I tell a real story about
something that most people would never
admit to because it makes you look to a
lot of people bad. It may or it makes
you look like a pervert or anything,
but I don't believe in that shit.
I don't buy it. And, and um,
anybody knows me knows. I'm just not hung
up on that stuff. I'm really not. And uh,
uh, and I wouldn't change that
experience for the fucking world.
What's that guy's name?
Vincent Gallo as what his name is he the
one that did that movie brown butter.
We're Chloe and she still has a career
and she blew him in the movie the movie.
And in the scene, she actually sucks
his dick and he kept, you know,
I notice about, especially women
when, uh, what I notice about, um,
I told that story and I were
a lot of women in the UCB.
Women were really open when
women were really like, found.
Like I had a couple women say hi.
I found that story really
honest and refreshing. And,
and, and how do you end it?
What do you say he received? The theme
was it was a slippery slope once you,
like if somebody calls you about an orgy,
if you don't turn around and drive
home immediately and throw handcuffs on
yourself, anything else is a slippery
slope and you're going down that slope.
If you're a guy like me. So you got
to fucking, you know, and that's, and,
and you know that story about getting a
call like that is what a lot of us deal
with on a day to day basis with
our addictions. Whether it's,
I'm trying to stop smoking,
I'm trying to stop drinking,
I'm trying to stop fucking watching
porn all day. Whatever it is.
People have these addictions trying to
stop meth. I'm trying to stop heroin.
These, it's the same addiction, man. It's
the same. It's the same impulse. And,
and so just to suggest that I don't have
some of that in me and that I in the
past haven't acted on, that
is dishonest. And by the way,
his concern is suggesting I'm not human.
Fuck you.
If you've got a judgment on that. I, I
thought it was awesome. And you know,
and that's how it is. What do you
think makes that impulse? What is it?
It W I know exactly the
legendary purposes. It's,
I know exactly what I think it is.
I think that that kind of behavior I
heavier ultimately does two things.
A couple of things. Historically
it threatens, first of all, it's,
it's unsafe activity, but you can actually
catch a disease and you can spread it.
So there's that. I mean, I use
condoms and stuff, but there's this,
there's this notion that you historically
have you had sex with a lot of people.
You came down with a shit like syphilis.
And we have it,
we have a historical memory of promiscuous
behavior leads to really shitty
diseases.
That's the first thing.
But I also think that a society has to
have certain norms and certain rules. Um,
because that was always the way you were
able to be more profit, more efficient.
I think when you had a credo that
people bought into, they were,
it was easier to organize things.
It was easier to create a
cohesive culture, uh, a cohesive,
a belief system.
And those are very human
impulses and developments.
And so when you have somebody who decides,
I'm going to follow my appetites and I'm
just going to fuck and be a real slot
or a real, you know, a real dirt bag,
whatever, these are the words people use,
I think we all go though, all of us
rightly in some ways go, well that's,
that's really indulging your appetites
and nobody can sustain that because
actually what leads to
that kind of behavior isn't
necessarily anything positive.
You're certainly not
going to develop a right,
you know, you're still generally
considered unsavory. It's, it's,
it's base behavior.
It's giving in completely to the beast
and a lot of people that supported our
freaks. That's right. Other
fellow freaks. We're all freaks.
If we weren't freaks then, then
youtube and I mean red tube and, and,
and all these things important wouldn't
be a multibillion dollar industry. But,
but you, you, you have that
we have a culture that's
obsessed with purity. I mean,
this Anthony Wiener thing,
it's obsessed with it.
The guy had to resign for
sending a picture of is
thinly clad package to go to a
coed. Wow. Wow. You
know, it's very strange.
But what do you think leads to what,
what purpose does that addiction have
in, in human beings? Why do we have that?
Why does it exist? Why is there this weird
thing that makes us fixate on things?
I know that there's a book I read
called the selfish gene. I know that,
that a scientist, um, I
can't remember who wrote it,
but I know that a scientist would,
um,
would suggest that genetic variation
has both ends of the spectrum.
So you have to sort of have, um,
the need for sex is very strong in,
in human beings.
And I would imagine that you have examples
of people who have a very strong sex
drive and they're on one side of the
spectrum and other people that are asexual
and it just probably, you can chalk it
up to hormones or whatever it might be,
but I don't even necessarily mean
sexual. Uh, I, I just mean why,
what is this proclivity for addiction
that people have for compulsive behavior
for or impulsive behavior rather than
male couples have an impulse maybe. Maybe.
First of all, it's they're
trying to fill a void, right?
You're trying to feel something.
I think it comes down to the juice.
Do you think it's because we don't
live hunter gatherer lives safe?
I was going to say,
I was going to say that I think when you
have to track down a deer and kill it
and that requires extreme behavior.
And in some ways I mean it,
it requires adrenaline.
It requires endurance,
it requires a supreme
aggression. You, when you kill
an animal, like the, you know,
we came up millennia killing
animals with a spear or a boner,
you smell that blood, you have to skin
it, you're involved in that animal's life.
And I,
I would imagine that the activity
of hunting on that level it takes,
it's a huge rush.
It's why people get addicted to war.
So you think there's like some sort of
a gap and then there the average person
working a nine to five existence with
some sort of stayed behavior pattern that
they have to follow throughout the day
that these people have like a hole that
needs to be filled?
No,
the porn comes in or drugs come in
or there's no guessing come in. Yeah,
that's what he does because we have
a lot of needs. And I think one is,
and by the way, I'll tell you what
needed probably fills. We have needs.
We have a need for certain certainty.
We have a need to feel like I
know where my paychecks coming.
I got a room full of men. I think we have
a need to connect with people, you know.
But we also have a need a lot of that
behavior. When you gamble, look at it.
When you,
when you show up in a room and six girls
you've never met are there to fuck you
or that you don't even know what
they look like and your heart's
beating. You know what? You're really
responding to adventure, uncertainty.
The need to not know what's coming next.
And human beings have a very deep need to,
to put themselves into the unpredictable,
just as much as they have a need
to be in the predictable bit.
But if you look at somebody
who doesn't have anything that,
that unpredictable in their lives, what
happens? They get fucking bored. It's,
it's why when you make all the money
in the world and you've done it all,
a lot of people get a sense
of loss because there's no
longer that feeling like,
like Zoros a mountains to climb. Yeah,
well, sorrows. The guy who, the rich,
the multimillionaire, billionaire
guy, he was a, uh, I think,
I believe as a Jewish refugee and
it was 15 or 13 years old. Um, uh,
and hunger as a Jew, as a Jew.
And he was hiding from the Nazis,
meaning I have to hide from the Nazis and
a otherwise he was going to be killed.
And, and he, he said, um, that in many
ways those were the most exciting, as,
as terrifying and horrible times.
They were also the times he felt the most
alive because he didn't know if he was
going to make it till tomorrow. And,
and human beings I think have a very,
very deep, deep need to be put
in the unpredictable. And, and,
and there is,
there's a way to do that that's positive
and there's a way to do that that's
negative. And as you get older, like I am,
you start to realize that
going to orgies, um, um, uh,
and that kind of stuff,
gambling, those are not positive.
They're not necessarily positive things
to do you because you pay a price for
them in some ways.
If you become a sex addict and you're,
you're chasing skirt all the time,
you're going to pay a price in connection
and intimacy, I believe. Yeah. Um, um,
I, I've had to confront that in myself
and I've had to deal with that on, on,
on a personal level. And so you don't
get away with anything in the world. You,
you, you, and, and the best way to do it
is not to be too strict with yourself,
to fucking be forgiving of yourself
and others to realize that we are all
hanging on by a thread in
one way or another. You know,
I've watched really good people try to
quit smoking and they can't fucking do it.
You can call it, you can tell
them they have weak character,
but I don't choose to believe that.
I believe that they're just fucking
week like all of us in one area.
Weakness, courage, intelligence, these
are all compartmentalized skills,
compartmentalized virtues.
Uh, nobody is, you know,
very few people are sober
all the way through.
And if you are sober all the way
through and you don't have any vices,
you might be fucking too
boring for me to hang out.
Want to know what doctor Drew's vices
are cause he know he's got them. Well,
and you know,
a lot of doctors though,
doctors I'd noticed tend to be
very sober individuals. I agree,
but I wouldn't want to go home. They
can doctor drew, how about that?
I would tell them how it would second
hand smoke funnel ticket in his brain.
But when,
when you see a guy who was constantly
around people who are fucking up left and
right, but yet he and his life is like
very together, very together family that,
that, that, but then that's, that's
part of his, what makes him feel,
but that's a positive addiction.
That's,
I mean doctor truth always
challenged with a new person.
He's going to try to help. He's trying,
doctor spends his life solving problems.
Cousin Nate. Yeah. Not only does
he do that, but he's always on
the love line show as well. People don't
realize he's still got that radio show.
So every day, every day.
It really does help people.
I mean he really got us to a out and
needed advice and I don't think he's
helping those celebrities.
I mean you can say they are,
but those dudes need a paycheck.
I mean,
I guess any possible treatment and maybe
maybe the idea of shocking them and
putting it into the public law actually.
Yeah.
Maybe putting him in the public eye
actually puts more pressure on them and it
actually makes it more real.
I'm fascinated with,
with this notion of what
discipline really means and what,
what self restriction really
comes down and you know, what,
what impulsiveness is worth
and how much is dynamic, crazy,
unpredictable behavior worth in a, in
the dynamic of a machine. You know,
because the human being,
you look,
look at a human being in the
context of being a unit and there's,
there's qualities that I appreciate and
one of the qualities I like impulsive
people. I like wildness. No,
all my friends are impulsive.
All my friends are crazy.
Me Too. You know, it's more, it's more
color. It's fun to be around. Yeah.
I mean we've talked about Jimmy Burke.
Joey Diaz is a perfect example.
You're a perfect example, you know,
to other people. I'm an example.
It's like we're all kind of the most
fun people I know are all pretty fucking
crazy. Yeah. You know, I mean you,
you don't get interesting and
funny without those weird sorta.
I agree. And I like to hold
onto a lot of my impulses.
I like to hold onto a lot of my, whatever
you would call the beast and the flesh.
I mean,
I do think that there's a,
there's something beautiful
about learning how to be in,
can total control of yourself,
of your appetites and everything else.
I think that is a virtue and I think
that's something people as adults,
as you get older, should strive for. Um,
but I also think that I don't want
to lose all my, uh, all my crates,
especially as an artist,
especially as in the chair,
you needed to be forward to
the wildest moments on stage.
You're letting people know when
those wildest moments like,
I've been to this crazy place.
That's why I'm a standup comic.
I get up on stage and try to make
people laugh. It's called look at me.
There's a whole line I'm
trying to fill in all or not.
I don't want to lose that
whole, I really don't. I mean,
you ever see a really good actor.
They're uh, they're basket cases,
they're fucking basket cases. The key is
to be that basket case, but to be happy.
And as a comic goods,
there's a dance and it is possible
and it's possible to put your,
your balance in the correct way so that
you still are energetic and enthusiastic
and creative.
But yet you still have that there's a
part of your brain that will flip over to
the dark side. You just gotta be able to
control it. Well and, and you know, but,
but let me tell you something,
when you start talking in terms of I
better learn how to control it. You know,
that's not how people are.
That's not how people control themselves.
The minute you start saying things like,
I can't do that. Not gonna do that.
Like I was doing with that,
with that hotel room. Right.
I'm not going to go up there and fuck
those six girls cause it's, it's wrong.
That doesn't work for me. That's
not going to work for me. Well,
what does work well,
I think you need a different car.
You either need a different
kind of philosophy.
But I think more importantly when it
comes to dealing with an addiction,
I think you've got a substitute.
I think you've got to associate,
you got to figure out a way to associate
that behavior with nothing positive.
And, and, and you've got to be able to
associate a different kind of behavior
with something that's more pleasurable
because it was, anytime you do that and
add in any addict counseling, right?
They tried to get you to replace her
addiction with, you know, start gardening,
get obsessed with something.
It's gotta be something fun.
It's like when I tell people that, I know
that people that don't work out okay,
and I noticed that they just
can't work out. And what they,
what they get tired the minute you
start talking about you've got to start
eating better and look at them, you
guys. Yeah, yeah, because you go,
you got to start eating better and
you've got to start working out what they
think is,
I got my God.
That means I'm going to have to sweat in
a gym and I got to know what all I want
to do is show you very gently and slowly
how much better you feel when you are
in shape versus when you're not.
And once you feel the difference,
you will slowly start to go to that.
And when you go back to your old habits,
you'll go, damn, I don't
feel as good as I did. I,
I gotta I gotta do something here and
you'll try to get out of that state.
It's the only way I think people really
change. I really, I really believe that.
I don't think you change
with a gun to your head.
I think real change happens when you,
when you see and understand the
difference and, and, and that that can be,
that can be taken to I think movements
like w like al-Qaeda's movement,
that's Muslim fundamentalism.
When you show them a really
interesting program, uh,
in,
in Yemen where they take
these young idealistic al
Qaeda guys and they get these
Muslim scholars in a room.
These like really kind of like smart guys
who've been around older guys and they
debate them, they challenge
him to a debate and they go,
what are your ideas on Islam?
You're on Islamic fundamentalism,
you love the Quran.
Let's have a talk since I'm any month,
I've been doing this for 50 years.
What are your ideas?
And they just dismantle their ideas
mentally. And a lot of these guys just go,
I didn't know any of that. I've been fed
this kind of thing. And they're like,
well this is how it is.
And let me show you the examples in the
Quran and all of a sudden they go and
their minds change.
And if you want to change what you're
saying is you need to go to the Muslim
religion, you'll stop beating
off and fucking whores in
a hotel. Well, well, well,
well, well religion, whether
it's Christianity, Muslim,
Islam, Buddhism, Hinduism,
Ken can serve that function and has
for many addicts and as a really a real
place for people to kind of live.
They go with the 12 step program.
One of the reasons why it works is that
you submit to a higher power. Exactly.
It sounds ridiculous,
but as a tool is a mental tool using
it as an operating system that you,
you're going to operate your mind under
the confines of this Christianity. Look,
man, I've 0.0 system. The
biggest, the biggest thing,
the biggest problem we have
in some ways and, and the,
the worst thing that artists
can do for themselves as to say,
I'm all my genius comes right out of me.
It's,
it takes a lot of pressure off you as a
creative person or a person in general
to say, you know what? I'm not perfect.
I'm going to let something else guide me.
I'm going to let something. Um,
so if you're an artist, he's,
I'm like Flannery O'connor,
that wonderful thing. She goes,
I don't sit at my
typewriter to write at all.
I just sit at my typewriter and I sit
there in case something happens and it's
something starts working its way
through me. I'll start typing. Right?
But the pressure off you cynical people
will look at like Pressfield's book like
the war and they'll go, well,
this is poppy cock. That's
fine nonsense. That's fine.
But it's not effective. It is.
If what people don't understand
it, and it may be incorrect, it may be
all within the confines of your mind,
but if you operate on the principle that
you are enacting the muse that you were
contacting the muse, then it really
does work. Ken, can I, can I,
can I Sinek kind of Cynak explained to
me why when I hear a piece of music I
start crying because it's so beautiful.
Can you explain
mathematically how that goes?
I'm not interested at all I know is I
start crying because it's beautiful.
A lot of things that cannot be explained
what it does, laws fires me. I hear,
I hear like a beautiful piece of music.
You know why I got into standup?
I remember when I got to stand up after
I heard your album and that Voodoo
Punani song and all that stuff and I'm
a seriously, and I went home that day.
So you don't know this. I
never told you this. I'm, it's,
I'm glad I'm talking about this because
I listened to your album and I had to
leave early. I got out of there and
you couldn't, and you got mad at me.
You call me, I'm gonna go. You just
left without saying by just took off.
You know why I took off?
I couldn't handle being around you
because I was so not only inspired,
but I went, my friends doing something
really special here and I have,
I know I have something in me
and I'm not living up to it.
And being around him has reminded me of,
of the fact that I'm not
living my fucking life.
And I remember you called me real mad and
I made up some excuse. Like, I was like,
I started telling you like some
excuse and then I went, dude,
I gotta be honest with you. I, you
fucked me up a little bit. I said,
that song and that, that your
jokes were so on inspiring to me.
And I went home and I started writing.
And so that's what happened to me.
That was a huge catalyst for me.
I went home and started writing because
after I heard that song and after I
heard those fucking jokes, you would
come to those, God damn you're judge.
This was I don't know how many years ago.
They were so fucking well formed.
You were such a title wave.
It was like an example for the first
time where I went, I saw an artist,
so just peak come together and just put
out the power you putting out with so
retarded that it was changing.
It was changing the whole fucking room.
People were like, what the fuck
this guy's writing songs he's doing.
And I remember going, I got to taste
some of that. I got to have some of that.
I've got to get the fuck out of here. I
get that stuff. That's what you need, man.
And if you don't have that in your life,
you've got to find it.
Either surround yourself with friends
who do it, go go to ted.com do what?
Do whatever you have to do,
man. Find it. It's out there.
And the beautiful thing about the
technology and this is for young people,
is that you can spend your time listening
to music and reading about what Lady
Gaga Ward or the gym,
or you can fucking open your mind to a
whole world out there that is going to
bite you in the ass if you're
not ready for it anyway.
So start opening your
mind and start reading.
And it's important to not give in a
jealousy when you see someone doing
something that you're not doing and you
feel like, fuck, I'm not doing. There's a,
there's an instinct to protect yourself
by bullshitting yourself and becoming
jealous and bitter and talking
shit about that person.
And that's where haters come from.
What haters are 100% of all haters in
the world are unrealized potential.
It's 100% accurate. I'm not a hater.
I'm, I'm a, I'm a pretty nice guy.
Easy going guy. It's because
I'm successful. Well,
when like Michael Jordan's not a hater,
you know what I'm saying? I mean,
you know what I mean? I mean like
when you get to a guy at that level,
they're not haters that the real haters
are and they see someone doing well and
it bothers them to a person like
a Michael Jordan or a winner.
They see someone doing well and it
inspires them to take it up another notch.
I've always, I've always, always
tried to look at things like that.
When you see something great and if
it's a friend of yours, there's nothing.
You have to use it as inspiration.
It's supposed to inspire
you and haters and,
and that notion is a, is is what that
is, is it's a skewed perspective.
I think what happens is a lot of
times they say, well, you know what?
There is scarcity in the world,
so there's only a,
there's only a certain size of the pie.
And if you're doing this, you've taken up
all the pie and there's no room for me.
Not True Man, not at all. There is no
scarcity in tangible way of thanking you,
open yourself up to something beautiful
and great and let that work through you
and really be effective. Be
astonished by it. Be scared by it.
DPP be brought to your knees by it.
Whatever it takes you will,
you will find way more strength in
that surrender to, to the beautiful.
Then you will when you close
yourself off. And all of us, man,
all of us had this notion to go,
I'm closing myself off. Fuck this.
Everybody wants to win the lottery,
but the lottery will fucking ruin you.
You have to earn the whole thing.
In order to be a real man or a real woman,
you have to earn the whole thing.
And the crazy thing is to be the man.
To get to that point,
to be the man,
you literally have to not ever be possibly
the man because you have to get to
the zen state where there is no the man.
It's all about the work.
It's all about what, what genius you're
putting out is all about whatever,
whether it's music or whether it's
writing or whatever the fuck it is.
It's all about finding that real pure
place. So there is never the man,
that's when the muse kicks
in. The idea of this, I,
this all comes from somewhere else.
It's like maybe it is just an attitude
that allows you to bypass the ego.
Maybe that's what the Muse is.
It's just a scientific or a method of
thinking that allows you to bypass the
ego. It's effective, whatever. It
is very effective. And I think also,
and so you're never the man, you
never feel like the man, well,
you're bringing me to like the
notion of celebrity for example.
That's a really good point because
celebrity actually doesn't exist. Like,
like you've had celebrity for a long
time. But like just with me now, things,
you know, things were
starting to, you know, you,
I go to places and people recognize
you and they want to take pictures or
whatever and, and you
think to yourself, well,
I'm doing this TV show and I'm doing,
it wasn't,
and I guess in some ways I'm making
lots of money and I've kind of arrived a
little bit. I mean, I'm
kind of like, you know,
I'm a working actor and there
is zero difference actually in,
in uh, what it takes for me to
keep myself inspired. And if,
if anything that's nice,
it's a nice thing,
but it certainly plays no real
part in my overall fulfillment,
which is really interesting. You know,
and I, you know this really well. I mean,
you know,
I've been with you in Vegas.
I remember what the height
of fear factor when,
I mean you had to literally go to the
corner and rub your eyes because they're,
they, everybody would take, they
just, everybody wanted a picture.
I really want to touch. Everybody
wanted to be around you. That doesn't,
that becomes, I guess
in a lot of ways, um,
the exact opposite of what you're
going for. It's a privilege. It's nice,
but it's actually a distraction.
It's actually not. It doesn't,
it actually doesn't exist. It
doesn't exist, but it does. It does.
I just mean it does. Something he
has to deal with is, yeah, it exists.
But it is weird.
What I mean?
Is that what you think celebrity is going
to be and then what it actually ends
up being two totally different things.
Yeah. That's all. That's all it is.
That there is a dance that you have to
do to in order to not get sucked into the
wave, not get sucked into
the gravity of the situation.
Don't believe it or buy into it.
You know, some people never do know.
Brian, you've inspired people. This
was a good podcast and you know,
I've talked to so many people and I talked
to a lot of them this weekend we did
a the Irvine Improv and there
was a lot of fun and uh,
we talked to a lot of people that are
podcast fans. And one of the things,
the number one thing that keeps
coming up as these people say that it,
first of all,
a lot of people listen to it at work.
They listen to what they're doing,
stupid shit that they don't like doing
and they just love the fact there's
something like this out there.
And two,
they say it gives them an opportunity
to look at things completely different.
It's shaping the way
people think. Man, there's,
there's a difference between
what we're doing here. Then the,
the sort of the average radio show and
the average podcast is we're not afraid
to talk about weird deep shit and go and,
and because of that,
it's allowing other people to consider
possibilities and ways of thinking that I
don't think they would have.
Like it's a privilege and
I know the privilege for me
to man, it's all, you know,
it's great to be on the podcast.
It's, it's, it's, you know,
and I have people come up to me
all the time now. That's amazing.
I'm going to give a little while listening
to this thing right away. I'll be it.
I'll be at the, uh, San Francisco
Punch line. Have you done that?
Punchline is great.
I'll be there on August 10th to the 13th.
That's my birthday. The 11th it is. Yeah.
I'm going to call you ever done that,
that happy birthday. It's
amazing. It's a great, great club.
It's one of the best clubs. It's a
perfect height. It's one of those places.
It's got the low ceilings.
It's tight.
I think it seats probably two
5,300 and now it's perfect.
I can't wear a dude.
I was just in San Francisco recently
and God gave me a Bill Hicks last live
performance at the punchline of last time
I was there and gave it to me on DVD.
That's what's so amazing about
being a comic, because you get to,
you're performing with such a
history in rooms like that. Oh yeah.
I'll put one of those. The
punchline. That's one of
those, I'm doing the ice house,
not this weekend coming up,
but next weekend,
which is the 22nd and 23rd
the Ice House in Pasadena,
and that's a small place.
It's gonna sell out quick,
but that place is the same place
it's been for like 30 plus years,
man. And there's photos on the
wall of people from the bullies.
I think it's one of the oldest
comedy clubs in the country.
Yes. Yeah, it is. It is.
It's just doing the ice house. Come on
down. If you want to do this weekend,
you want to do it next weekend, come
down to do it. Gets a 22nd and 23rd.
Come on down, bitch. I'm down.
All right, beautiful. Um,
look, I love you man. You're
the best. Brian Cowen,
B r y a n c a l l e n on Twitter
and Brian [inaudible] dot com.
And uh, you already know he's going to
be at the punchline in San Francisco,
the 10th through the 13th,
which is a fucking awesome club.
If you're in San Francisco, you think
Brian's funny, deep on the podcast,
you got to see a stand up. You're
standing up has come. I mean,
I remember when you were doing
that alternative bullshit
just standing up there
with your hands in your pockets and
your fucking crushing it now, man.
It's awesome. It's awesome to see.
Thank you. And um, and that's it.
You dirty bitches. That's the end
of the podcast for this week. Um,
I got some shit to do and I'm not going
to be around all week. So very busy.
I've moving and shaking. I'm in a
movie now and I dance. I'm doing. Yeah,
for tomorrow. So if, if anyone wants
their fixed, I'll be doing four live.
Who are you doing them with?
Start off with naughty show with Sam Aaa.
Then Bobby Lee and Ari
Shaffir at two o'clock.
I'm going to be a good way to work.
It's going to be a good one.
Four o'clock Tom Segura ski
and then six o'clock uh,
and then,
okay,
well try to keep it together for all
those times and don't make a sad face.
So I'm so tired. Budget,
all of these podcast,
if you're going to commit
to doing that many podcasts,
you've would have take some five hour
energy, right? Yeah. Damn right, Baby
Montana. Have you been
there before, by the way?
Never been on my tab. I haven't last
frontier basically. I'm pretty well.
All right. You dirty freaks. We
love you. We are you. You are us.
We Are Legion and we love the flashlight
and we do not forget big kisses.
Go to fleshlight.com excuse
me, Joe, to Joe rogan.net.
There's a guy who owns [inaudible]
dot com he wants a lot of money.
That's the story.
And I'm not willing to give it to him.
Joe rogan.net and click on the link for
the fleshlight entering the code name,
Rogan, and you will get 15% off
the number one sex toy for men.
We are ironing out all the legal details
when it comes to the Onnit labs. Um,
uh, new, true genic,
whatever the fuck it's nootropic
formula for brain pills.
I don't know exactly why it works,
but it fucking works like a motherfucker.
There's some nootropic for me,
those are neutral,
but foremen that were coming out with
that is a, it's very fascinating.
It has a very tangible effect on you
thinking very tangible effect on your
memory and your energy, your overall
energy during the day. I find myself,
I take a lot of them when I go on
the road and I don't get tired.
I'm not as tired as I normally am from
traveling. They're fucking amazing.
I don't know what's going on. It might be
giving me brand canvasser but sir, sir,
sir, sir, listen, this fucking show
was over about three minutes ago,
but I kept going. So good
night and god, speed.